from all of you thank you for coming
and with that let us proceed to the to
the business at hand and I would open um
I would I would start with a house bill
299 representative Weber do you have a
motion on that
microphone
I beg your pardon I would move itl on on
199 299.
and I would like to speak to my motion
sure is there a second for that
representative Parma seconds a
representative Weber
um we are all concerned about
everybody having access to care
and that's a fundamental principle I
think for everybody on this committee
my concern with the bill as it is
written
is that
it
requires
Physicians to take into account things
that are not generally accepted good
Medical Practice
um because
whether we like it or not we ration
Medical Care all the time and we
hope that care is directed to the
neediest
rather than the loudest
and secondly my other concern with the
bill is the creation of a private right
of action which I think is very
unfortunate and not helpful so that's
that's my concern with the bill
okay thank you any other discussion
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman
um I think some of the reason why I
support this bill is actually rather
similar to similar to the concerns just
voiced I believe that we need to make
sure that when care is rationed it's
based on specific medical need as
opposed to any societal issues we need
to be looking at who needs that care
that can have something where it comes
down to socioeconomic because you need
to make sure that the care is
appropriate to where somebody is being
discharged and that's a medical need we
have some drugs that are only approved
for people of African descent and that's
a true medical need in order to have
that for those people I believe that
this language actually makes it more
clear that this needs to focus on just
medical need but I recognize that
there's a difference of opinion here so
this is one that I'll be writing a
report either it's majority or minority
whichever way it is in order to make
these statements thank you
other comments other discussion
yes representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman I I think often we
are debating bills um and ignoring the
subtext behind the bill like
a recent example is we had a whole
debate about
um reporting abortion statistics and for
the most part people don't talk about
their feelings about abortion being
legal or illegal
um
in this case the sponsor who brought
this bill was very clear about what the
intentions were of the bill and he
started off his
um he started off his presentation
saying that the terms Health Equity and
anti-racism were just the other words
for
um discrimination against white people
essentially
so I would ask you
you know of course it's a very complex
thing to decide who gets what care
but
because I think those intentions are
very dangerous
and I think there are inequities in
health care that need to be addressed I
will certainly vote against this bill
and I would urge other people to do that
too
thank you
other discussion yes representative
Palmer
so um just speaking as a practicing
physician who and I think the example
that was brought up during the testimony
had to do with a treatment during covid
and I would be very nervous about having
any kind of thing about action simply
because that was shifting ground it
changed from week to week what was the
accepted who who should Pro be
prioritized to get which treatment and
if you're then trying to you know look
back and you know did the doctor do the
right thing at the right time almost
impossible so I really would oppose this
bill based on that part of it
thank you thank you representative King
thank you chairman McDonald
um I'm going to be supporting itl but
maybe not for the same reasons everybody
else is I believe in Freedom of
Association and I don't believe in
anti-discrimination laws I think we
should get rid of all of them and I
think we should let people
um associate freely and there might be
cases where
certain doctors want to only
um
treat people that they like or that are
like them and I don't see any problem
with that actually I think that might
increase the quality in health care
right now there's a lot of people that
they go to the doctor and maybe they
don't think they're treated very well
and they
um on the inside think oh maybe it's
because I'm a woman or I'm black or
something like that and if you could go
to a doctor that only treated black
women then you might feel better in that
care and you might get better care so I
know I'm living in Fantasyland again but
once again I'm against this bill but not
for the same reasons as everybody else
thank you
thank you other discussion
okay so you know the discussion I'll ask
the clerk to call a little
representative land
no
representative Cushman no
representative Bill King no
Representative no
representative McLean no
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri no
representative Reed no
representative pelosa yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative fredis yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro yes
representative priest yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Howard yes and
representative McDonald no
12 to 8.
representative you're going to write a
report
thank you
all right when would you like our
reports in by
um
well can we can we do them by tomorrow
at noon perhaps that'd be great that'd
be great yeah I'm in the process of
reviewing a bunch and by the way thank
you everyone for I got a bunch of
reports in thank you I haven't gone
through them all yet but thank you for
that and yeah by tomorrow would be great
sure go ahead
so you want them all by tomorrow then
I'll soon even today would be great but
today will be a little tough but
sure sure thank you
okay I'm moving on now the next bill for
consideration today is
House Bill 557 representative profile
did you want to do you have a motion
is there a second
okay
representative McLean seconds
representative Weber I have a motion uh
an amendment that is being drafted for
this one I know that the hospital
Association asked the and in the third
line to be changed to or
and I I put that in to have drafted up
and do you know when the amendment may
be available no I don't
um
this is the rules
okay sorry you're right
so we're good okay I was um so on House
Bill 557 representative colqualt do you
want to speak to your motion
uh yes I I continue to hold that this is
a uh an important build by virtue of the
fact that
decisions of this gravity should be made
by the legislature uh decisions
compelling people to uh to take certain
medications or or treatments or to give
those to their children is a very very
serious decision and should not be
delegated beyond the legislature so I I
believe that this is
this is an important step in the right
direction
thank you another discussion
representative Shapiro
yes um
I I think we're just going to disagree
about this I under I I understand
um
representative kovoltz
um here we go
you know desire to have legislators
decide this I mean I think be also
because it's such a grave decision I
would see it as being beneficial to be
kept in the hands of professionals
um with adequate oversight from the
legislature but especially given the
level of partisanship and contention in
politics these days I think I mean a
scientific decision initially
um to be researched and made by the
legislature is not the best way to go
I think we should have oversight and
make be able to make the final decision
but I think we should give these
decisions initially to people who are
steeped in medicine and Science and this
is their area of expertise this is why
we hire them
thank you
uh yes representative Murphy thank you
Mr chairman
as representative Shapiro said I suspect
you understand where I would come down
on which side I would oppose an OTP on
this
um in for part of the reasons that
representative Shapiro talked about but
this is really a medical decision that
really should be left in the hands of
those that make Public Health policy and
medical decisions
the they have actually stated in
testimony that they have no intention of
mandating vaccines you know you know
going forward necessarily changing their
vaccine requirements they haven't had a
you know an additional vaccine since
2003 that was mandated
um
I just feel that this was a reaction to
covet obviously but on the other hand in
order to really make a decision that is
sound for patients it really ought to be
done by those that have expertise in
medicine but also in public health so I
would vote against and urge others to
vote against an OTP motion
thank you
uh representative McLean
thank you Mr chair
um
I'd actually put together an amendment
for this but you know upon reflection I
think the bill is pretty good as it is I
think bottom line is the rulemaking
authority is relatively recent so this
doesn't put us back into territory that
we haven't been in before and it's not
like we're bringing in new vaccines
every three or four months in fact I
think it's been 20 years you know and
the the biggest lesson that I learned
from the covid pandemic is not the
mistakes were made yes of course
mistakes are made and I can forgive
people we're all human beings but the
biggest disappointment was just how much
I thought Supreme that speech was
suppressed and and that really bothered
me a lot but the one place that had an
antidote to that actually was the New
Hampshire House of Representatives which
is incredibly open and Incredibly
transparent and so while my wife might
be mocked on Facebook or something one
place anybody could come was the New
Hampshire House of Representatives
whether you were smart whether you were
dumb whether you were knowledgeable or
whether you were a kook everybody could
come and things just kept going on now I
looked at a rules making hearing back in
2021 which had to do with the vaccine
registry and what they were looking to
do is they were looking to eliminate the
opt-out and in fact role people who had
opted out actually into the registry of
course a lot of people showed up they
were very upset and so what happened and
that rule-making hearing is everybody
says oh my gosh we have all these people
here they're upset and there's way more
than we thought we're going to have to
you know shelve the hearing you know now
contrast that to the hearing that we had
last week on gender affirming care I
mean
lots of passions lots of people and the
the chairman had a stack of pink cards
that thick and we went through every
single one of them there was no talk
about hey we're going to have to back
off on this hearing and I remember being
in judiciary when Marjorie Smith was the
the chairwoman and that would be an
abortion bill that suddenly was bigger
than we thought
I'm going to recess the hearing for 20
minutes we're going to move it over to
the state house and we're going to go on
and so that is what we have here in New
Hampshire with this legislature and I
just think you know I'm not an
anti-vaxxer personally but I know that
there are a lot of anti-vaxxers and my
solution to that is not to be less
transparent my solution to that is
actually to be more transparent and I
think that this is an excellent Bill and
I'm going to support it
representative King
thank you chairman McDonald's I support
this bill
not just Statewide but federally
legislatures have abrogated their power
to the executive branch and this is one
tiny little step that we take that power
back
departments and bureaucracies are there
to enforce the rules not make them and
that's our job thank you thank you of
the discussion representative Weber
I just want to note that during the
initial stages of covet the legislature
did not meet at all
um which would be a roadblock to the
legislature taking charge and when we
started to meet again it was with very
little process and
nowhere near as much thought as we
normally give to our bills far less
rigorous examination and that goes back
to the reason why I am
opposed to the bill
thank you representative cofult
so one of the concerns that we heard was
the ability to
um to to act quickly in the in the face
of a Public Health crisis and I think in
fact that the our experience with covid
um validates the concerns that arise uh
that prompted this bill and in fact the
you know we've we've recognized in
previous discussions around this bill
that the um the emergency power statute
grants the governor and the executive
branch a considerable latitude in the
case of a public health emergency
and that um
that this is something that uh that the
executive branch could have acted on had
they wished to impose such a mandate
um I think the experience with the uh
the covid-19 vaccine actually has uh
has has provided us with a case study
and why rushing something to uh to
Market
um although it uh you know there there
may be reasons for doing that rushing it
to Market and particularly mandating it
uh when it is rushed to Market is uh is
is not a good idea and I think the
reason many people have so many very
serious reservations about the uh the
covid-19 vaccine and its side effects
um just speaks to the need for
um for for a bill like this with respect
to vaccines in general that people
should have an opportunity to weigh in
in a fully transparent legislative
process through public hearings and that
the need to push something forward very
very quickly is not only
um
a a a a poor reason to to you know to
delegate this responsibility
um it's it's probably pretty bad public
policy to uh to rush things forward that
quickly in the first place
yes representative Reed thank you Mr
chairman I think that how covid was
handled and the um covert vaccine
mandates and the rushing through has
shaken the faith and trust in the
community
around vaccines and health care in
general I think this bill would be a
step in the right direction in restoring
that trust and with transparency and
assuring that people have a say in what
they put in their bodies and their
families bodies thank you very much
thank you
of the discussion
a representative palazzov
um uh I I suppose this bill and I
suppose discussed yes we have some
concerns about
partisanship in the body but also we can
see that
federal agencies are also make the
decision not just on
on the on medical reasoning and
so I would like to see like
some responsibilities
because if some decisions were outlier
to learn I would like like to see that
uh uh collection measures were made but
what we often see is people
fail to success somebody is on on HIV
and then he is promoted and then the
same person is around on lockdowns and
on masks and on other issues and the
person is still being promoted so
and when I see it I don't trust
those agencies to make Right medical
based decisions for us thank you thank
you another discussion yes
representative Shapiro
I just have a question for um
representative co-fold and I I'm I may
be mixing this up with something else
but I I I was
I kind of remember that an amendment was
either brought or talked about that
would um
that would
make the three
vaccines that are already were already
brought through rulemaking and make them
permanent in statute
um now I don't know if someone just
talked to me about amendments or I
actually saw something like that but
maybe you could just clarify that you
know so there there was a proposed
amendment which has not been brought
forward to do that that is also what
happened last year when I brought this
bill forward for the first time
um and that Amendment
passed a lot it actually only added I
believe it only added varicella last
year that Amendment passed 11 to
11 to 10 in um
in this committee last year so
um yes that has been discussed my
objection to that my concern with that
is that
um it it still does not afford the
legislature an opportunity to conduct a
full and transparent public hearing
process and and
to be accountable for the decision of
whether or not to add those to statute
another discussion yes representative
Cushman I'll be brief because I know
that we want to get to voting here
um I just want to say that I support
this bill as written very much so and
especially not
um putting some of those veteran rules
in statute also for example hepatitis B
vaccine I think if that had been left up
to the legislature it wouldn't have been
added to the requirements for schools
it's a disease that is primarily a risk
for IV drug users and requiring it for
three-year-old children
you know to go to school I think that
that was a decision that the legislature
would not have supported and hepatitis B
positive children are in maybe in school
too and we you know you don't know
so there's just there's just some
argument there again about handing this
authority over to
um you know administrative rulemaking in
the department so I think it should
definitely stay in the legis be back in
the hands of the legislature thank you
thank you another discussion
seeing none oh I'm sorry representative
Murphy just be clear relative to
representative Shapiro's comment so the
the amendment that was initially talked
about eliminating these vaccines from
statute is not going forward this is
gonna as written as as written currently
in what we have right now is that
correct my understanding representative
profile so to clarify their
some vaccine mandates currently are in
statute some vaccines currently are in
rules the proposed amendment and the one
that came forward last year moved
well the the bill as drafted
would would simply say whatever in
statute stays in statute whichever in
rules stays there until those rules
expire
but rulemaking power is not granted
going forward so they could not be
renewed the amendment would have moved
one or more it depends on which
amendment we're talking about but would
would have moved one or more from Rules
into statute
so that as we revoke rule making
Authority for anything going forward we
would also be
um
essentially
making those putting putting the the
ones that are currently in rules in
statute
just to follow up sure follow up so to
be clear
the rule as it stands or the statue that
stands varicella the highly contagious
Hepatitis B in h flu will sundown
in 2026 unless it's otherwise reinstated
is that correct that is correct yeah
and again with respect to Hepatitis B I
think the the large concerns
are you know given that it is generally
speaking an adult lifestyle disease
um there are those who might choose not
to have it for their children
um I think the the main concern with
hepatitis B is the extremely serious
consequences that arise if an infant
somehow manages to contract hepatitis B
um you know it's it's a you know it's a
potentially fatal incident so those are
the but but in in answer to your
question yes those with sunset unless
the legislature makes an affirmative
decision to add them to statute
representative Weber
did you have a question you would raise
your hand I thought oh I'm sorry it's
just
okay all right representative Leon uh
thank you Mr chairman
um I said on the administrative joint on
gel car and this addresses one of the
deficiencies in the current rule making
process right now a rule would be only
be denied because it is contrary to the
statutes so when when these vaccines
have been added through administrative
rules there's the only way that's the
input of the public is recognized as if
the department chooses to make a
recognition of that input and change
their guidelines these are things that
should be discussed and they should be
brought to the legislature because they
have large impacts I would expect that
if this bill passes that next spring
that for next next year but while we're
still in this committee we'll see a bill
to bring those vaccines and add them
into the statutes that should be a
separate discussion I can probably
predict what will happen with that and
they likely would end up being adopted
but there should be an opportunity for
this discussion this this is an area
where we're not talking about access
we're talking about requirements and the
public should have the opportunity to be
heard which is one of the things that
New Hampshire does best
of the discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the roll motion is ought to pass on
House Bill 557.
representative land yes
representative Cushman
yes representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes representative
McLean yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Reed yes
representative pelosa yes
representative Weber no
representative McKay no
representative Freitas no
and representative Cannon no
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro no
representative priests
representative Murphy no
representative Palmer no
representative Howard
and representative McDonald yes
10 to 10.
all right so that will go with no
recommendation oh yeah representative
Weber
having been told last week that we have
to then make the other motion before we
send it without recommendation I move
itl
motion is itl
uh is there a second
representative Palmer yes representative
I'm sorry
I know well the thing is yeah
just turned around
um I'll have to come up with a different
excuse now any discussion on this motion
uh representative did you want to speak
to that motion at all no I think we've
gone around adequately on this one okay
no discussion
all right is the clock ready ready okay
um proceed motion is now itl on House
Bill 557. representative Leon no
representative Cushman no representative
Bill King no representative Koval now
representative McLean no
representative Seth King no
representative Missouri no
representative Reed no
Representative pelosa no
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes representative
Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro
representative priests yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Howard yes and
representative McDonald no
10 to 10.
representative Weber
I was going to ask representative Murphy
if he might write the minor the the
statement in favor of of Ideal gladly I
was just waiting for representative
Shapiro to you know nominate me well I I
thought we'd kind of dumped on him last
week so
okay
moving on
um next one we will consider is cacr8
a representative
um pushman did you want to I mean I'm
sorry representative mazura
thank you Mr chair I moved to itl on
cacr8
is there a second representative Kushner
oh second uh representative Missouri did
you want to speak or did you say sure no
I will sure go ahead yeah
um I think the consensus is right now
that they're no one is being denied
birth control
um a problem really doesn't exist there
was no one here except the bill
sponsored to testify to that and this
would involve a Constitutional Amendment
which
in my opinion is not needed so
thank you representative Weber
I would just state that if we are going
to amend the Constitution I would favor
an amendment that deals broadly with all
Reproductive Rights and decision making
but I I think that piecemeal for one
particular smaller segment is not wise
the Constitution for me is a a structure
and a framework not the details thank
you another discussion
ready I am motion is a itl on cacr8
representative lamb yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes representative
McLean yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Reed yes representative
peloso yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yeah
representative fredis yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro yes
representative priest yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Howard and representative
McDonald yes 20-0
there was no objection and we will put
this on the consent calendar
moving on
um
proceed now to House Bill 277
representative Cushman do you have a
motion
uh yes I move that HB 277 be inexpedient
to legislate
okay is there a second
representative lay on seconds discussion
do you want to speak to emotions sure
um I think this bill is just too messy
it puts
um
it puts some mandates on providers to
refer to a very very small pool of
providers that possibly exist in the
state that are willing to do these
procedures where others aren't
um I think that there's just a lot of
um issues with it it's
it's just not straightforward I do like
the idea of it in general
um I think that you know women should be
able to make medical decisions for their
bodies and it's a shame that
um some doctors think that they know
better about women's lifestyle choices
um but
the bill is written I just can't support
so
thank you
all right yes representative Weber
um I second everything that
representative Cushman said I also note
that those of us who were here last term
and remember all of the discussions
about the patient's Bill of Rights and
how they get amended and how they get
posted now they get shared with patients
that too is a framework for how patients
are going to be treated by their medical
providers and the interactions between
providers and their patients and it is
not the place for uh detailing specific
procedures if this was something we
wanted to do specifically it needs to go
somewhere else in the statute as far as
I'm concerned particularly with all of
the qualifications that were in it so
for that for that reason and I I also
second the fact that I definitely
believe that people have the right to
make their own medical choices but the
providers also have the right
to decline to do something that they
feel is
inadvisable for whatever reason but they
have an obligation to send them on to
somebody who can take care of the issue
thank you representative Leon thank you
Mr chairman we worked with the sponsor
of this bill to try and be I I'm I'm
absolutely sympathetic to the fact that
women are denied sterilization when they
want it and where they may be looking to
interrupt generational abuse
um I know people that were unable to
interrupt that but when we got into the
wards and trying to make this actually
work as intended without creating new
problems we just weren't able to get
there so I agree with what the other
Representatives have said so far and I'm
supporting the itl as well even though I
support the underlying effort this is
just not the right way to do it
thank you other discussion
so you know all the discussion
representative Weber
and I just would ask that whoever writes
the report put that last sentiment in
the report I think it probably was going
in there anyway but I just wanted to
make it clear and I thank all of you
okay thank you
so you know other discussion the motion
is itl on House Bill 277. it's the clerk
ready I am I proceed representative Leon
yes representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofo yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Reed yes
representative pelosa yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro yes
representative priests yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes representative
Howard
and representative McDonald yes
20-0
there was no objection we will put that
on the consent calendar
we searched up for our consideration
will be Mr chair can I ask a question
quickly about cocr
cacr8 do I need to write a report on
that on the I do okay we do yes we do
thank you they still get a vote
um okay next up uh House Bill 378
representative Leon do you have a motion
um thank you Mr chairman I move
Amendment
2023-0492h on House Bill 378.
okay is there a second to the motion
so representative McLean seconds
um this was handed out at the time of
the hearing all this does is it changes
the title and I can read that title um I
can send this up to HCS for a print
um but I will read because
um so the reason for the amendment is
because it was a previous the title
referred to a previous draft within the
whole drafting process and the title had
not been changed and that lead up to the
bill being introduced the amended title
with this amendment says an act
requiring a health care provider to
inform a patient who may have been
drugged or sexually assaulted of their
right to a medical examination and the
collection of blood urine and other
evidence as part representative Missouri
yes
representative Reed yes representative
peloso yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
fredis yes representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro we're on the
amendment right on the amendment yes
represent priests yes
yes representative Murphy yes
represent Palmer yes
representative Howard
and representative McDonald yes
20-0
representative land you have a motion uh
yes thank you Mr chairman I move ought
to pass as amended by Amendment 492h on
House Bill 378. is there a second
seconds
discussion
representative
um
hi now you can see me I can see you um
so um not everyone was here to hear this
bill so if we're voting in favor of this
we're voting in favor of
medical people
telling a patient who has been assaulted
in some form or another that they are
entitled to have
samples collected
and we're
is that what we're voting for
um yes if I can answer that that is what
that is what we are voting for this
isn't creating a new right to these kits
because if you believe that you have
been assaulted or drugged in a sexual
assault and that sexual assault includes
um attempted rape it means groping of um
of sensitive areas of the body
um it's a very broad definition of
sexual assault as it should be because
yes
um and as I remember the the sponsor who
had
not been penetrated and so when the talk
of a kid coming up the hospital
personnel
assumed there would be no semen sample
to collect so they denied her a kit
the hospital seemed to have a very
narrow view of of what an assault was so
this would broaden that because the
sponsor that brought it up was concerned
that she had been drugged and only the
kits that they have at the hospital test
for that
yes I just wanted to be clear that we
got all the facts straight so okay thank
you and then if I make sure go ahead
thank you Mr chairman
um so yes this this provides that the
Physicians would need to inform somebody
um a man or a woman who was sexually
assaulted or which includes the attempt
at rape um that they have the ability to
collect this evidence
um with that does not mean that they
need to stock them and have them on hand
it just makes needs that means that they
need to inform them of that right and by
being required to inform them of that
right they need to know they will then
know that people have the right to
collect this evidence
there have been some concern about
whether a test finding no drugs in the
system would be conclusive that you were
not drugged that's actually not the way
that tests work that it would just
simply say that they did not find any
drugs it doesn't mean that you were not
drugged and this is an area to
um
I went to college I knew plenty of women
that and my sorority and others that
were in these situations but they did
not think that they would be listened to
so they never reported anything
and Reporting an attempt is actually
very important because many of the
sexual assaults there's many that have a
history and a history of escalation and
so by collecting this information it can
start moving towards finding these
people earlier in the progression before
Things become worse so
um this this is
I I support this
I support this because
feeling that nobody's going to listen to
you and they're not going to take
evidence
is something that you end up living with
the rest of your life and that giving
this opportunity and simply saying you
know if you feel that happen if you feel
that that happened we can get that
evidence to collect for you I think is a
major step towards healing because we
speak about all the increase in
mental health issues suicidality and
addressing these at the time of a
life-changing event is one way to break
that cycle
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman
um I was not present for this hearing so
I feel a little bit of it at a
disadvantage so I hope you'll indulge me
and
um were there people who came to oppose
you know to give testimony in opposition
and if so what was their what was the
you know brunt of their testimony
representative Palazzo a U.S that in
response to his question or well uh um
when police testified they said that
some police departments for example in
smaller towns they have only a small Dom
size fridges to collect samples from
those kids before they are being
transferred to permanent storage place
so my uh I I would say I'm ready to
donate to my towns if they need a larger
fridge and i would support our efforts
if we need to
collect samples of actual assaults I
think it's one of primary roles of us as
a government thinker representative
McLean and then representative farmer
you know uh thank you Mr chair and and
maybe the the vice chair could clarify
this because I just my understanding
from the testimony was that there was
something that this added and that is
that you know this line here for the
purposes of this paragraph assault
includes any unwanted sexual touching
and I thought that was an addition and
for that reason the New Hampshire
Coalition against sexual violence and
the police were opposed to it because
they're saying now what could actually
happen is could actually impede the
opportunity to get a conviction because
you haven't had penetration you're just
you know grabbing someone
by the buttocks for example and so as a
result of that there's nothing that's
going to show up in the kit and in the
past you know they would say no we're
not going to offer you for this reason
because it might be it might counter the
opportunity to get a conviction so that
I think that element if that's an
addition that does concern me
um I do agree that
um you know when we spoke with the the
the chief of the Newport Police
Department he says they review every
case and in those situations where a kit
is not given and it should have been we
do go back and we do update our
standards I do think that we should be
looking at a way to give a woman an
opportunity to get a second opinion so
you don't have to wait for a review
console to come back and make that
decision but I don't think this language
as it's written
um I would be inclined to go along with
the New Hampshire Coalition against
sexual violence and police where I'd be
at this time
representative Palmers so getting back a
little bit to representative Shapiro's
question
um
we had a meeting with the New Hampshire
Medical Society and there were a number
of people there who gave opinions on
this which and and the part that I'm
that concerned them with a little bit
the same as representative McLean so I
won't go over that part
the um
the uh
sexual assault nurse testified against
it sort of based on
some of these concerns about
practicalities not not that the idea
wasn't good but just
saying our system works pretty well and
this might might make us stumble over it
the ER Physicians and nurses were very
concerned about the particularly about
the drugged one partly because of the
what the drug tests do and don't do and
partly because of issues with chain of
um chain of custody of the evidence and
their their ears are already overflowing
and if they have a room and a nurse who
has to stay with the patient until the
police get there they're really worried
that this would um just be an another
impossible thing to to manage on top of
what they're already doing
um and I think the the ER physician
um
said you know we we offer this but don't
make don't don't put it in you know
don't make me document it and then ding
me or have some penalty if I didn't
document that I did it or so there were
mostly sort of practical objections to
this bill
um not not spiritual
um and so I think that
thought was maybe this could be done in
a different way to to broaden maybe the
approach but not but not clog up the ER
thank you representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman
um so just to speak to a couple of
points that were just mentioned
um as far as I I think that this is just
since it's just informing them it's
really not changing what it's it's in
the situation that occurred where the
woman was not offered this and actually
was denied it when she asserted her
right to have it it was
drug metabolites that were being looked
for not semen samples because there was
a sexual assault that didn't involve
penetration and you know the the doctor
um had their own definition of sexual
assault and it was more narrow than what
sexual assault truly is defined as so I
think this will just correct them and
and give them a clear idea of you know
any any situation like that they should
inform the patient that it's that it's
available
um so in instead of suppressing that
information make it very easy for the
person to make a decision if they want
to do that or not thank you thank you
representative Missouri yeah thank you
um so representative Shapiro I also took
notes um from the Newport PD I there
were three things that he mentioned one
was what's been alluded to is toxicology
so that if a test is taken and it's
negative it could be harmful to
prosecution that was one of the things
he mentioned and then storage is they
said they had no space for an influx of
additional samples he did mention that
as well and then testing is uh many
hospitals don't already have the ability
to test for substances and it costs them
one thousand dollars per test to send
out so those were that's something that
a PD said but with that said
um I'm still I'm still going to support
it so but there were that was something
that was mentioned that I thought was
helpful actually to hear
so
another discussion representative King
um this was originally a bill that um
well let's just say I I had a lot of
mixed feelings on this bill I see both
sides of the argument
uh very clearly and I was vacillating on
which way to support it and so my
question is for representative Weber you
had mentioned you will not be supporting
this bill and I would very much like to
hear why thank you
I think my my concerns have already been
expressed my understanding from
discussions with people who were here
because I was not was that there were
concerns both on the part of emergency
room personnel
about their ability to
deal with this
as it's written and also concerns on the
part of the Coalition against Domestic
and Sexual Violence who are the people
who support
people who have undergone assaults and
for that reason I would I would tend to
defer to them on this issue
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman and
um yeah when I was listening to the
testimony before and I think one of the
biggest concerns that people had and
this is in reference to representative
Shapiro's question previously was the
line in the uh in act uh to offer intake
and preserve so that was going to put a
significant burden on this amendment is
basically eliminating that action there
the amendment which
I appreciate trying to get to some
middle ground or compromised position uh
it just basically says you have to
inform the patient the the the
testimony from police was as mentioned
by representative Missouri there were
three components of that as well that
they already had protocols in place and
to take store and do it properly was
going to put an undue burden however
having said all that it would sound as
though I would lean towards supporting
as amended but I would not in this
principally my my position is that
this is I don't believe in legislating
medical care now anecdotally you know
people have bad experiences with many
Industries including medicine I
appreciate that but I don't think that
mandating medical care which I believe
is done properly the majority of the
time anecdotes aside
there's a place to educate to adjudicate
any of these potential problems that
providers
um don't do that would be the Board of
Medicine I don't think it belongs in
statute to require them to do something
that they do the majority of the time so
I appreciate the anecdote I appreciate
the concern I appreciate the intent but
I cannot support it even as amended but
I also appreciate the attempt to try to
get to something that is a bit more
palatable
thank you thank you
other discussion
no representative Weber
I was just going to raise the question
about whether people thought if we
retained this bill we might be able to
come up with language that was more
appropriate
and I I just put that forward as a
suggestion it is certainly for the
moving parties to decide whether they
want to do that or not
thank you
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
for that situa that suggestion um I
think that's probably would be a good
way to move I do want to make the point
that the Coalition against domestic
violence felt stated that unless there
was penetration there was no need to
collect a sample kit which I find very
concerning this is a very good reason to
retain this and work on this because
there may actually be larger issues that
we're unaware of and we may need to look
at at the whole system of funding and
making sure that we are collecting the
appropriate forensic evidence so that we
can stop things early so with that I'd
be willing to withdraw my motion in
order to substitute another
and I can withdraw my second okay uh
representative land uh thank you um I
move that we retain house bill 378.
and I will second
okay is there any other discussion on on
that motion
any other discussion on this bill the
representative I think that's an
excellent idea
okay thank you of the discussion
seeing none I'd ask that the clear
caller will
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofo yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Reed
yes
right
miss me
oh you know why
okay never mind all good representative
Missouri
yes
Representative peloso no
representative Weber
yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas
yes representative Cannon yes
representative
representative Shapiro yes
representative priest yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Howard
and representative McDonald yes
19 to 1.
thank you
representative Palazzo
okay next for our consideration is the
house bill 323
representative land you have an
amendment uh thank you yes um I if I can
I would like to move Amendment
2023-0934h copy of the amendment is
being circulated to house bill 323.
um
I had attempted to introduce an
amendment last week when we met that
Amendment had removed that whole
introductory section that spoke to the
roots and origin of this bill this
amendment now instead of removing that
just adds this and replaces section two
which is the one that spoke to the
mechanism so we're retaining the
honoring honor of our late colleague
Catherine Rogers and the entire Genesis
of the bill within the legislative
findings in section one that was very
important and I apologize for that
Omission I was a bit in the let's drive
forward and get this done while
forgetting the necessary consequences of
that
um sorry actually I can speak to my
motion I don't know if there was a
second deserve a second
I'll second that second representative
seconds okay thank you and I'll continue
speaking to the amendment
um it also takes the advice to have it
so that the members are appointed by
different parties
um the language starting at line 10
through 14 says two members of the House
of Representatives and two alternates
with one member and one alternate
appointed by the Speaker of the House of
Representatives and one member and one
alternate appointed by the minority
leader
if the Speaker of the House of
Representatives is a member of the
minority party the second member an
alternate should be appointed by the
majority leader since we've had that
situation in uh not so not that distant
history
um I believe
or because I was outside of it I may
have had that wrong but I think that
that's good practice then uh finally on
line 30 it adds the role of biomarkers
in the duties of the committee so
basically this the original Bill had
looked at the idea of digging really
really deep into the science and getting
a really good functional knowledge of
specifically what's emerging what's
coming out and
quite frankly anybody who had the time
and bandwidth to do that job shouldn't
be making 200 every two years they
should be making north of 200 000 a year
working either for industry or for the
investment industry
um and so that was it was well-meaning
but far more allocation of resources
than any of us have here this committee
makes it a little bit more Nimble and
able to respond in speaking with the
sponsor of the bill
um
the idea I raised the idea of requiring
this committee to meet more frequently
um but that but the point was brought
out that that could just make busy work
that this committee did not see any
necessary reason to meet this is
enabling but not mandating what this
committee needs to do it leaves them
ready to respond should they be needed
but does not charge them with with any
of these I do expect that anybody who
wants to be appointed to this committee
however will be digging into these
emerging medical Technologies and we'll
be excited to do so so I don't think
that we need to require them to meet
more frequently
so that's my summary discussion on the
amendment representative Murphy thank
you I just had a question I when we
reviewed this last I remember we had a
change for the amendment and Katherine
Rogers and biomarkers Etc I had written
down here on line 23 the committee
instead of Xiao May
um is was that not the intent I
in your Amendment
uh line 26 now
says the committee shall and I thought
to be nimble we were going to say may is
that not correct or am I mistaken what I
heard
um thank you I didn't write I didn't um
catch that when I was sending in that
draft Amendment
um if that's critical enough for us to
send this for another redraft we can do
that or else we can have that request
made to the Senate if this passes on and
that should be an easy concurrence if
that's the case I'd be happy with that I
was just trying to clarify what we
talked about that's all okay thank you
oh yes representative Shapiro
I'm not asking this question to ensure
that I don't get appointed but could you
give an example of a biomarker clearly I
won't be asked to be on this committee
um thank you there
some of the biomarkers are ones that
show up on staining you would have a
her2 positive breast cancer
there's a whole bunch of different
genetic indicators that are biomarkers
that allow you to shape and shift what
the directed therapy would be one of the
big benefits with this is that sometimes
you find out that a drug only works in a
subset of patients so you're able to
tune it for best efficacy in those
patients and bring it to Market so they
can have it without denying care because
only one in five people benefits but
that one in five benefits dramatically
so a particular gene mutation would be
an example of a biomarker um
thank you
the Weber
I'm thinking of the commercials that I
hear all the time about this treatment
is for these are television ads that are
broadcast all over the place this is for
people with hard hard to negative
something or other positive
breast cancer and I think oh my gosh you
know that's getting a little specific
but it they are specific but I would
also say that I I thank representative
Leon for incorporating all that stuff
into the amendment and I too am willing
to overlook the xiaomi thing I think we
can take care of that subsequently and
without a floor amendment in the house
so
uh thank you thank you
of the discussion yes representative
McLean
thank you Mr chair
um you know I'm I'm all in favor of
emerging Technologies but I have to be
candid I I still struggle with how this
is going to work and really be of a
benefit to bring forth emerging
Technologies I guess I'm okay going
along with the committee on it but if I
could
if you could maybe just give me a better
understanding of how this actually moves
the ball forward and this structure does
that
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for that question
some of the areas within here would
actually allow us to address part of
what we've identified recently as gaps
we had had some safety risks that were
not appreciated until after after some
people's lives had been lost I actually
did change that other language because
we had had the one about
basically about non non-competes and
that was far too close and it was
absolutely a different tasking and
um
so I amended on the second page line 10
and 11 to say of the things that are
reviewed policies laws are
administrative rules which impact the
public disclosure or withholding of
safety concerns surrounding emerging
medical Technologies we passed on a bill
to have the
um
the transparency advocate for the parent
for the patients to go to the Board of
Medicine this would be another way to if
there's anything that comes up where
there may be a policy from one of the
boards of medicine or there may be a
rule or there may be a law that is
harmful that we can look and address
those with and get into those
discussions before we get into a bill
drafting situation so we can make sure
that it's targeted and and I I do have
yes and so it can let us get ahead of
those situations it also can look at
removing barriers for access to emerging
medical Technologies
um in the original draft that
specifically was targeting a lot of the
reimbursement issues but there's more
than that too it's also making sure that
with the expanded clinical trials that
we mentioned on line 29 that we're
bringing these to the community settings
and not just academic centers because
that's where most people are treated
here in New Hampshire and that's one of
the best ways to get these treatments
out when you have something that's
related to biomarkers it's very rare so
you need to cast a very very wide net
and you need to find those patients
where they are this also would be a way
to expand the industry base here in New
Hampshire for medical devices
biotechnology a lot of those there were
there was some manufacturing that was
happening up near Dartmouth that is no
longer happening and it would be good to
see if that's simply a market change or
if any of our laws are the ones that are
pushing these these businesses out
because I would like to see a robust and
thriving biotech can device industry up
here there's so much talent down in
Massachusetts I say we let people work
here in New Hampshire instead of having
to commute so that would be another
opportunity for this it's it basically
says there's lots of opportunities what
can we do that's good
representative Palmer
and so the one of the things that
representative Leon said in there is is
uh
the idea of safety and some technologies
are pushed in advance of what where they
are actually effective and so this would
be another great thing for this
committee to look at
thank you
of the discussion representative Shapiro
I would just say that now that I'm clear
what a biomarker is
that my daughter
is alive today because she's been
treated with a you know a gene specific
medication a gene targeted medication
and um
so I know it's fantastically expensive
she has insurance that pays for it
and the idea that someone wouldn't get
that or that there'd be some obstacle to
people getting that
um we shouldn't let that happen
the discussion
seeing none I'll ask the Clark Hollow
role a motion is ought to pass on
Amendment zero nine three four h to
house bill 323.
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative kofo yes representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Reed yes representative
pelosa
yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yeah
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro yes
representative priests yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Howard yes
and representative McDonald yes 20-0
hey um representative Leon um thank you
Mr chairman I move ought to pass is
amended by Amendment
934h on House Bill 323.
is there a second representative
representative Murphy I think seconded
first but
um
any discussion on on this motion
did you okay no this uh essentially
replaces the the amendment we just
passed replaced the core I think the
acceptance of it hopefully means
acceptance of the entire Bill passing
okay thank you of the discussion
saying none Mr Clark are you ready I am
okay go ahead uh motion is auto pass is
amended on House Bill 323.
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes represent Bill King yes
representative coppo
yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Reed yes
representative so yes
representative whoever yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative
representative Shapiro yes
representative priest yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Howard
and representative McDonald yes 20-0
there's no objection we'll put us on the
consent calendar
this time I know there's a number of
amendments we are still waiting on so
um I would like to ask that we recess
for about 15 minutes and see if we can
that's sufficient time Adam Vice
chairman
I think that should be time to collect
any amendments that are upstairs and
shake the bushes to make sure that we're
getting them as quickly as that we can
so I think if we come back at 11 does
that work for you okay okay we'll be in
recess until 11 A.M thank you
I think so
I'm gonna run upstairs
okay
foreign
thank you
under sandus is coming for a Republican
state
to no catch
okay let's uh reconvene and um
yeah
406. okay uh and let's proceed to House
Bill 406 and
um representative representative you
want to make a motion on that
yes I move to retain House Bill 406.
zero second
representative McLean seconds
uh representative Leon uh representative
profile did you want to speak to your
motion sure
um so I am moving to retain my own bill
um
because
Ms manahan has brought some additional
information to light over the weekend
that uh
that calls into question the need for
the bill and I think requires further
consideration as to how we would do this
so I was prepared to bring forth an
amendment
um that would
clarify well which would add web portal
access
because apparently currently the the
issue in question with the Elliott
letter and Elliott hospital is not the
only
organization that does this I believe
Dartmouth Dartmouth Hitchcock does as
well
restricts parental access to certain
medical records of a minor child once
they turn 12. if the parent wants full
access they have a rate under HIPAA they
have they have a right to access their
child's medical records
but the the
organizations are making it more
difficult to do that in other words the
parent has to file a formal written
request they have to get it on CD or USB
drive or paper from the hospital or or
healthcare provider
um
what what Ms minnehan has pointed out is
that they're under the cures act there
was something called the information
blocking
um or it restricts what they call
information blocking and that just uh
this past October HHS issued a rule with
respect to the information blocking
statute which which would make it
um
it basically says you you as a
healthcare provider you cannot put
barriers in the way of somebody having
access to information
so it appears it and we'll have to see
how that plays out at the federal level
and how the nuances of that play out but
it appears that as the blocking rule
goes into effect that may resolve the
issue the amendment that I brought or
that I was prepared to bring forward
would have added web portals and again
Ms minnehan suggested that that would
take some time to implement because if
the portal is currently
are not
designed to
slice and dice information at a granular
level necessary
to to comply with with the law and the
amendment as written that would take
some time to develop and it would mean
that we'd basically be putting them out
of compliance until they can get that
done so I I don't want this bill to go
away but I do think that we need some
time to
um to see how things play out and I
believe that you know there are several
other bills in play right now including
House Bill 10 which would potentially
impact parental access to medical
records so I think that the prudent
thing to do at this point is to retain
this one and revisit it if and when
necessary
thank you representative Shapiro
um
thank you Mr chairman um while I well
when I practice as a mental health
clinician I was totally committed to
working with families and families being
part of the situation intuitively when I
first heard about this bill I would have
probably been against it
um so I really just want to compliment
representative kofold for being like
um so thorough and so careful about
including all the exceptions initially
that are already in federal law and
state law working collaboratively with
the hospital Association
um you know really just doing incredible
work to make it um
to you know to make the the point that
parents should be involved while taking
into consideration all the nuances I
really appreciate your effort
thank you
another discussion
seeing none I'll ask Clark to call the
wall the motion is to retain house bill
406.
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative profile yes
representative McLean yes representative
Seth King
yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Reed yes
representative pelosa yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yeah
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro
yes
representative priest yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Howard
and representative McDonald yes 20-0
okay thank you
next up for consideration is house bill
408. uh representative pofult
thank you I
um
I move
Amendment 20230577h
of which copies have been distributed
before but additional copies are going
around now
you said zero five seven seven eight
correct thank you
sir
hey is there a second to that over the
end of lay on seconds
representative profile do you want to
speak to your motion uh yes so again
this this does not
um this is the same amendment that was
passed out
at the I believe at the end of the
hearing
um
when I presented this bill
part of what I think
was of concern is that the statute
um
is not the statute that that authorizes
rulemaking with respect to Foster family
homes
um
it it may not necessarily
authorize
DHHS to impose immunization requirements
in that statute I think as the original
bill was written it seemed to validate
the assertion that that
Authority was being granted or is being
granted by current statute this rewards
essentially rewards the same
um the the same intentions that are in
the Bill without necessarily affirming
or giving cause to validate that
Authority under under current statute
thank you representative Shapiro
yes
um Mr chairman and representative cofult
I have a question
um that I don't know about whether it's
specifically about the amendment but I I
know that this bill is
put in because there's a concern about
foster homes and actually the perhaps
the biological parents of the foster
parents or other kids that are not
foster parents living in the home having
to take more vaccinations than is
on the school vaccination list
um
so this would say that they did that
they couldn't be required to do that
but could dcyf or the placing agency if
there was a particular medical issue
could could the placing agency like dcyf
say that they're not going to put the
child there because the children are not
vaccinated or would this Force dcyf to
place the child in that foster home in
any case even if there was a specific
medical
vulnerability related to
those vaccinations
I have to confess I don't know enough
about placement processes my assumption
is that
um
that DHHS has the latitude to judge
whether or not a foster home is
appropriate whether that
whether they have to cite a specific
rule in in making that judgment is is
not something I know but I would assume
that they would have that that Latitude
so I don't know if anyone else in the
room has an answer to that question
representative Weber
I'm not entirely sure I have the answer
either but I serve as a court appointed
special Advocate and as such I have been
involved a number of times with
placement and replacement of children
and I certainly know that the department
has latitude to change a foster
placement when the child is not
prospering
and I know that they do work very hard
at
um
matching the child to the home
sometimes with greater success and
sometimes with less success because of
the lack of foster homes which I know
representative kofalt talked to us about
at the beginning
um
I started out by
being opposed to this formulation
because
we ask homes where we place foster
children to jump through many Hoops that
we would not
that a a natural parent or a guardian
would simply be able to decide for
themselves
um I'm thinking that the more I read
this language and the more I listen to
representative kovalt's explanations of
it the more I'm persuaded that this is
not a bad way to go
representative Shapiro
yes um
I would just say that my one concern was
the question I asked and it's hard for
me to believe that the DC
dcyf would be forced to place a child
right even if there was a medical danger
or keep a child in a home even if
there's a medical danger so assuming
that that's not the case
um I don't really see why
um just because you're becoming a
licensed foster home that your kids
should have to have more than the
regular precautionary vaccines so I I'm
I'm I'm likely to vote for it and
representative Weber and just as a
follow-up I think that that also gives
uh dcyf the option of placing
a child in a foster home that the that
the parent of the child being placed
might be comfortable with as well so I I
think I'm fine with it
another discussion
[Music]
in the past
577h to house bill 408.
that's the clerk follow the rule
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Reed yes representative
peloso yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yeah
representative fredis yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro
yes
representative priest yes representative
Murphy yes representative Palmer yes
representative Howard
and representative McDonald
all right yes
twenty to zero
okay
representative Koval do you now have
another motion
yes Mr chair I move on to pass with
amendments on House Bill 408 with
Amendment
20230577h so
this has been made in
a second
representative McLean
any discussion do you want to speak to
that motion representative uh once again
I think we've probably had enough
discussions okay thank you
another discussion
saying not ask at the collaro motion is
ought to pass as amended on
representative Leon uh Mr chairman if it
would be helpful um does anybody from
the committee want to hear some answers
that we had had about the foster homes
and about the rule changes from a
representative of the department or are
we satisfied to pass this assuming that
there's no flaws that the Department's
worried about
okay
as long as somebody's here if you have a
brief answer
foreign
good morning my name is Abby Rogers I'm
the legislative liaison for the division
of Public Health Services I'll represent
that I'm here
um I can try to answer some of your
questions related to vaccination I am
not representative of dcyf uh but I'd be
happy to try to help with your question
that you had
sure go ahead representative
so the question really is
um
would dcyf or if it was a different
placing agency that contracted with dcyf
would they have the latitude to
um if we pass this bill and children in
foster homes biological children and
Foster homes didn't have to have these
extra vaccines with dcyf or the
Contracting placing agencies have the
latitude to not Place children in the in
that particular home if there was a
particular medical vulnerability
um
that would arise sure thank you for the
question my understanding is that
currently due to licensing standards and
certain requirements that certainly
children under the age of six I believe
are need to be in a home that currently
under current standards rate that uh the
Foster family is vaccinated and also uh
children with special medical needs also
have different requirements for having
those vaccination requirements in place
I do believe there are some licensing
regulations and federal requirements
that would stipulate that
um
and I would just share remind the
committee of testimony provided
previously that the requirements of
foster family
children specifically related to this I
believe in homes being vaccinated has to
do with the fact that some foster
children are placed in homes either
partially vaccinated or under vaccinated
due to asip requirements either because
the um the parent or the biological
parent is unable to be located that that
parent our Guardian are the only people
that can say that your child that the
child can be vaccinated if you will so
if in lieu of that this this sort of
requirement of having uh the the Foster
family vaccinated really serves as a
safety net for those under-vaccinated
children the only way I believe to
vaccinate an under vaccinated child if
the biological parent is not available
is through a court order so I think this
serves as a little bit of a protection
mechanism for those children coming into
a home
representative Weber
so as a follow-up
if you have
I think the tenor of what I heard from
representative Shapiro and I'll just put
it in my own as my own question
uh
the
if we adopt this piece of legislation
it still requires the list of
um
uh immunizations under 141c and it it
also includes the exemptions but would
the department not be free to pick and
choose among foster homes to fit the
right child with the right placement so
if you have a child with medical needs
if you have a child under a certain age
and the guidelines
exclude this particular Foster Family
you would simply go on and look at the
next Foster family I believe that's the
case I do understand there is a there is
a you know not a huge amount of foster
families as we as we talked about so
right if more we're choosing to um you
know not be vaccinated then that might
be a problem if you have a list of homes
and that you can't match up but I I
understand your question and yes and
and as a follow-up the countervailing
concern that we heard was people who
might choose not to be foster families
if they're required to get right
vaccinations so this sort of allows
people to turn either way yes exactly
and I would say that not as not being a
representative of dcyf the licensing
requirements uh you know those are
specific to the agency and I can't
represent those here too sure thank you
thank you representative Shapiro
yes thank you Mr chairman so
um you said as
as well as the reasoning that you just
gave for why the policy is as is now but
you also said that if this bill was
passed that there might it might be some
kind of conflict with Federal
Regulations about licensing foster homes
is that
or maybe this is outside of your school
a little bit out to my purview but I
will say that you know my colleague Beth
marginson who's the legislative liaison
for the uh for dcyf did indicate that
there would be some some licensing
issues uh related with requirements
there are federal requirements so again
that's not my purview but I am aware
that there could be some conflicts there
representative profile uh yes my
understanding is that the Federal
Regulations require that the state
recommend the vaccinations
in under these circumstances
but it does not require that the state
require them
right so to follow up on that um through
Federal Regulations federally asip is
the agency that requires that sets the
vaccination requirements and as we
tested by previously on vaccination
bills that New Hampshire currently only
requires 17 10 of the 17 requirements
then that would be under one RSA 141c20a
so we actually recommend less and do not
currently recommend all of the ones that
are recommended by asip for for school
and child care and also I believe for uh
for foster families
of the discussion
representative profile just just to
clarify though but
the rule currently for foster homes is
that the affected people in the
household
basically everyone in the household has
to be immunized with the entire
recommended asip schedule
with an exception and the exception is
because of the emergency rule issued by
DHHS in November which expires soon and
can't be renewed
covet is Exempted
for
everyone in the household and because of
the freedom and immunizations act the
covid vaccine is Exempted for the foster
children who are receiving a state
benefit because you can't be required to
take the coveted vaccine in exchange for
a state benefit so
the
the the I think what I heard you say is
that not all of the asip schedule
vaccines are required for people in
foster homes and my understanding is
that yes they are
um with that one exception on the
emergency rule which is the coveted
vaccine and that expires after six
months which puts us at I think another
six weeks or so well maybe less and it
can't be renewed so I think that that
essentially comes back
unless there's a permanent rule change
to exclude the covid vaccine yes um
that's true the covid-19 vaccine is not
required uh and I can't speak to the
update on the rulemaking but I certainly
can provide the committee with that but
I'm sure that dcyf is working on that
thank you
representative Shapiro yes um I'm going
to vote for this because I think it's
reasonable and because I think
um my experience with the foster care
system is that it's an incredibly
challenging job already and it's
difficult to find people and in spite of
people talking very dismissively about
foster homes that they're just in it for
the money they don't really get much
money so I I want to make it easier for
those homes so I'm going to vote for
this and I would just suggest that Ms
Rogers
you know alert people who are more
directly related to dcyf that if there's
really like if this is going to really
cause a conflict with the federal
regulations that they arrive at the
Senate when there's a hearing on this to
really work that out but I'm going to
vote for it today thank you thank you Ms
Rogers for coming up
other than yes representative McLean I
would just make an anecdotal statement I
have a colleague at work his wife's a
social worker so they have two foster
children two boys and so they have to go
through a pretty aggressive immunization
schedule to for because they also have a
son a young son and so they say dcyf has
been very good with us in terms of
spacing this out and I said well what if
you know covid was to suddenly be
dropped in he says at that point he says
that's a deal breaker he says my wife
and I we're both vaccinated but we're
not ready to take that step for our
young son and so unfortunately that
would take us out of the the program so
that's just an anecdotal note
thank you of the discussion
saying none I'll ask Clark to call the
wall the motion is ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 408.
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Reed yes representative
peloso yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yeah
representative fredis yes
representative Canon yes
representative Nutter Upham
did I hear a yes not representative
representative Shapiro I was distracting
her I'm sorry
um yes
and I hope I didn't put a vote in for it
if I if I influenced you there it is a
uh okay representative priest yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes
representative Howard yes and
representative McDonald yes 20-0
okay if there's no objection we will put
that on the consent calendar
okay next up for our consideration today
is uh house bill 642.
and
there's two amendments that are being
distributed on that
one is from representative Leon and
representative Weber right yeah
entirely sure that they're in Conflict
here but
I woke up on Saturday morning realized I
think I
just love my number
well we have to vote on them separately
we do but we don't have to we can
certain things
before we get into them
okay
um
it's been suggested that we just have a
general discussion before we actually
move either Amendment representative
Weber do you want to speak to yours
yes I I submitted mine in a panic on
Saturday when I said realized that I
thought I had said I would get an
amendment and I had completely spaced it
out until I was filling out my records
of what we did last week
uh the approach that my Amendment takes
is it removes
um
in section one it removes the first two
sentences and leaves only the last one
which says the department shall use
existing budget Appropriations to
negotiate reasonable wages and
appropriate service budgets with area
agencies and service providers
and I I changed the title of that
section to budget reallocation for
reasonable wages and budget Services
rather than the original which was
prohibiting salad salary limits so that
was just a real Bare Bones reallocation
of the amount of money available
so I would over to representative Leon
for hers
okay representative thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
Weber for putting that in I woke up
Sunday morning saying this flexibility
is really really good but maybe we only
want to have it for a certain amount of
time apparently a busy week
so so my motivation and just putting
um having this with um effective repeal
would be that because there's a whole
Redevelopment going on of this process
that this would be a bit of an
encouragement to within the next four
years actually complete that
Redevelopment and to put an end on that
flexibility because the idea of just
shifting budgets around in perpetuity is
a little scary but the idea of doing it
in these next few next few years as
we're trying to make the system work for
our most
our most deserving people in this state
that we have that flexibility
yes represented Weber my question is as
drafted and I I have no problem with the
repeal I think that that's probably
sensible we want to get this into the
budget process rather than piecemeal uh
I'm wondering if the first sentences you
have drafted it means that they can only
allocate
existing budget allocations to those
over 24 months and if so was that your
intent
as I was going through I remembered them
saying that without recognizing the
older budgets it was very hard to have a
reason for redetermination and that
there's some budgets that are 20 years
old and unless there is a situational
life change it's hard for that they
don't have a reason to review the budget
and so that appeared to me to be one of
the things that was important in order
to keep that flexibility
um quite frankly this is an area that is
a bit hard for me to fully understand
and I I thought that simply removing
that part on the wage caps which we do
not have was probably the best path
forward but I'm open to either one
representative Weber
I absolutely agree with the inclusion
there I just
as I read this quickly
I wonder if
that first sentence means
if somebody would read that
uh to mean that you can only do the
reallocation for those over than 24
months
I think that perhaps the way around that
would be to draft
a committee report that states that we
want all budgets to participate uh not
those older than 24 months or those
younger than 24 months so that at least
we have clarified for the record that it
was our intent here to allow that
reallocation to happen with all the
budgets not just
the older than 24-month budgets and
um but I'm I'm really glad you put in
that
that point because it certainly is a
sticking point for many many people and
as long as we're both agreed that we're
saying what we think we're saying I
really appreciate the work on it
I've done a bland you have anything
further yes thank you Mr chairman and
thank you very much I appreciate your
work in trying to get us the solution as
well I think that including that in the
report I believe you have far more
knowledge of this process I believe that
that's adequate to show our intent thank
you and we now have tapes as well
okay other discussion yes representative
although this is my fifth year here
bypassing both of these amendments
they're not in conflict with each other
no I would not offer my amendment I
would I would I would offer my second to
representative Leon's Amendment we
drafted them separately over the weekend
without any consultation so we don't
need both of them I feel guilty I read
the Sunday Times on Sunday morning
well if you'd if you drafted another
amendment it would be a little more
confusing so let's guess as well
of the discussion
okay with that uh representative land
you want to make a motion um thank you
Mr chairman I moved the committee adopt
amendment
2023-0940h to house bill 642. is there a
second I would second it okay
representative Weber seconds
do we have any further discussion
seeing none I would ask the clerk call
of all motion is ought to pass on
Amendment 0940h
Senate lamb yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofo yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Reed yes
representative pelosa yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative Fritos yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro yes
representative priest yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes representative
Howard yeah and representative McDonald
yes
20 to zero
okay a motion now before us would
presumably be ought to pass as amended
amended a house bill 642 representative
Palazzo would you like to make a motion
yeah uh I I move uh
octopus's Amendment
thank you is there a second second
representative web of seconds
representative do you want to speak to
that motion or
uh I think we covered it enough but I
think it's a good bill that can help
with current uh crisis of uh Workforce
shortage and inflation when uh rates in
the market go go up and because we have
actually some funds that were not spent
available it's a good measure to help
people thank you
any other discussion representative
Shapiro yes I I I'd like to ask somebody
who understands this better than me
um
makes me a little nervous when I don't
fully understand something and I have to
put on it so can somebody give an
example if we pass this bill what will
happen that doesn't happen right now
representative Weber
so this was in
something that I asked at Health and
Human Services oversight
currently we have a certain amount of
money allocated
and only 60 percent of the allocated
positions are full
so we have 40 percent of the money
allocated for people
for all the people who are reserving
services and right now everything's very
fluid on what gets funded but the
current bar is not that the legislature
hasn't funded adequately it hasn't but
we don't have enough people to do the
jobs either and so I asked at that time
G if we could take some of the money
that isn't being expended
and use it to raise salaries so that we
could get the rate of people being
served up to 80 percent of the services
and
the formulation here keeps it within the
original allocation the monies that have
already been allocated to these people
in these Services globally it allows a
redistribution
um to individuals and then with respect
to representative Leon's drafting of her
Amendment because you get a budget when
you start these services and it never
changes it doesn't change for inflation
it doesn't change for anything
the hope is that some of this could also
be
used towards
um people who have the older budgets and
are very restricted I think the and
correct me if I'm wrong the intent of of
both of us is to take the full pot of
money that's available and make sure
it's being used for services rather than
sitting unused
and then the goal also for both of us I
think going forward is this needs to be
addressed in the budget but with all of
the uh up in the air about how things
are going to look and what the services
are going to pay for all this does is
say you can spread the existing pot
slightly differently
thank you it seems like a brilliant
Amendment and a brilliant bill
oops another discussion
yes representative Murphy thank you I
have a question and it was just raised
in my head when representative Weber
said what she said and I just want to be
clear that
if we currently only have about 60
percent of the positions filled doing
the work that needs to be done and we've
allocated for 100 people and then we
take or whatever that number is and we
take all the excess monies and support
those that are doing the work
does and I'm always conscious when we
create budgets that you don't want to
put a tail on whatever we do today down
the road in a burden so does this mean
that the monies the excess monies that
help current employees and agencies or
people that provide services will this
mean a tale so that we cannot hire the
others and does it then if you do hire
more people will it increase or inflate
the budget in the allocating dollars
necessary well we're in a budget cycle
right now so the next budget is going to
be whatever budget Writers Do and as we
hear often hear we can't actually bind
the next legislature
um you know we've had policies that have
gone on forever we're in a period of
upheaval and the answer is I don't know
but I know that there's money there now
and there are people who need Services
now and if we paid a little more to the
people who are
doing Services now we could retain them
rather than having them go somewhere
else and maybe attract a few more so as
imperfect as it is I'm willing to give
it a try and
um
and as representative Leon has done it's
it's there's a repeal on this in 2027 so
if we've got it very wrong that's the
drop dead date but I think you're going
to find it's going to be limited by
whatever the budget writers do in the
budget going forward thank you
very much in favor
ability to provides I was trying to
understand the future consequences
that's also so thank you
another discussion
a saying none I'll ask the to call
the wall motion is ought to pass as
amended on House Bill 642.
representative land yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative cofald yes
representative McLean yes representative
Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Reed yes
representative peloso yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes representative
Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro yes
representative priest yes
representative Murphy yes
represent Palmer yes
representative Howard yes
and representative McDonald yes
20 to zero
there's no objection we'll put that on
the consent calendar
next up for our consideration is House
Bill 317 representative Cushman did you
want to make a motion
yes I would move that HB 317 be retained
thank you sir
I heard a second
representative Weber seconds
uh representative Cushman did you want
to speak to your motion
sure I think we just have a lot going on
with this system right now and it would
be good to keep this bill
um
in case you know as we see what what
comes with the systems redesign what's
going to happen over the summer and
um we have the other bill for the pilot
program
this is just a little premature and we
can hold on to it and see what changes
come and if we need to work on it or if
we even need it later
thank you another discussion yes
representative Weber and I would just
add that having the retained bill means
we can work on it and get it out to the
senate in January so it can move quickly
if speed is necessary it's kind of an
interim
interim stop so
thank you of the discussion
being done I will ask the clerk to call
the roll the motion is to retain house
bill 317.
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative cofo yes
representative McLean yes representative
Seth King yes representative Missouri
yes
representative Reed yes
represent peloso yes representative
Weber yes representative McKay yes
yes representative Freitas
yes
yes representative Canon yes
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro yes
representative priest yes
representative Murphy
representative Palmer yes representative
Howard
and representative McDonald yes 20-0
okay great
um we are still waiting on an amendment
um House Bill 136 which I was thinking
of taking up next
um but that is not here yet right let me
go ahead representative Leon correct we
are waiting to have printed an amendment
on 136
um and we have a total of five bills
left
okay
um there's no objection perhaps lunch
would be in order
to adjourn until a recess until one
o'clock or ten minutes of one
which one uh one o'clock
make a nice round number
well Santa Fe says till one o'clock
I'd like to reconvene
the executive session for the committee
on Health and Human Services and elderly
Affairs and as we resume I'd like to
begin with House Bill 136
representative Leon did you want to move
make a motion uh thank you Mr chairman I
would like to move amendment
2023-0949h to house bill 136.
is there a second
seconded by representative Weber
representative land do you want to speak
to your motion um yes thank you very
much
um this is a amendment that I worked on
with representative Merchant in order to
make sure that we were addressing the
desire to have collaboration in the role
making process and be able to have that
roll call vote either in support or
opposition to the proposed final rule
this is language that would allow that
and would allow
this process to be a little bit more
have the say of this this important
group a little bit better represented as
we move towards administrative rules
of the discussion
yes representative Weber
thank you and this is the work
language that was developed by
representative Liana representative
Merchant which he sent to me I have
another amendment which actually puts a
period in there and rearranges the
sentences a little bit but I don't think
it's worth arguing over the intent is
entirely the same so I'm perfectly happy
to go with this one
thank you
uh representative Leon um thank you have
you received that from OLS yet no okay
not yet okay
thank you yes representative
I have a question to represent
so is my understanding correct that the
bill was uh
about to require a roll call an
amendment say it's just an opportunity
thank you the intention is to allow an
opportunity for a roll call vote in
support or opposition and not to require
it but that there is an opportunity for
that Council to do so if they so choose
representative Weber and it's my further
understanding that that's not binding on
the department but it it's a way of
getting feedback to the apartment
Department
other discussion representative Palazzo
I just want to say so based on my
understanding I'm inclined to voting
against this amendment
so would it be possible to understand
which part of that was the concern or I
guess if maybe that's
I I mean
maybe a misunderstanding but I feel like
it's what what else down the initial
intention of the bill
by
not requiring but just providing an
opportunity
my feeling is like that original
intention was
like so it would be requirement and so
there would be a roll call vote and
there would be accountability and some
feedbacks a little processor
I think first of all it was
representative Merchant's Bill to begin
with so he has agreed to this because it
was language that he and representative
Leon worked on together so he's okay
with it and I feel free to represent
that because he also wrote me that this
language was stuff that they had worked
on together
um
I think that
my concern with the original bill was
whether or not
we were taking away the rule making
Authority
the department has and it doesn't do
that so that was my concern so the roll
call vote that gets taken is not binding
on the department but
they have to listen to what people are
saying and I think that we saw that also
when we heard people
who came about the system of care for
the developmental disability Community
people want to feel that their voices
have been heard and the answer may be no
but
as we all know when we vote in the
minority of any bill or other thing
I feel a lot better about taking it when
I lose a vote when I feel like I've at
least been able to explain myself and my
rationale and this because it was for
the benefit of the advisory Council
I'm really comfortable leaving it up to
the advisory Council as to whether they
want to vote or not they may be
rulemaking that they look at and they
say oh that's fine there's no need for
us to get together and vote because it's
okay
but this allows them the opportunity to
get together and vote either for or
against and presumably with whatever
whatever kinds of comments they want to
make so
uh in that respect I
you're right it gives greater latitude
to the council but I think giving
greater latitude to the council is a
good thing
I think that helps
another discussion yes representative
profile
thank you yeah I would just Echo the the
statements that representative Weber
just made
um I I don't believe that this
significantly Waters down the original
intent of the bill
um because it it does say that the
department shall provide them with an
opportunity to hold a roll call vote
which is is still binding on the
department to at least present them with
that opportunity so I think it's an
important step forward in terms of
providing some guidance to uh to the
department when they are making
administrative rules so I will be voting
for the amendment
other discussion
so you know other discussion
yeah I'll ask the clerk to call the wall
the vote is ought to pass on Amendment
0-949 h on House Bill 136.
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Reed yes
representative pelosov yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative fredis yes representative
Cannon yes
representative
representative Shapiro
yes
representative priests yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Howard
and representative McDonald yes 20-0
okay do we have another motion on the
main bill at this point representative
Leon thank you Mr chairman I move ought
to pass as amended by Amendment uh two
zero two
three-09498 on House Bill 136. is there
a second second
uh if you don't want you wish to speak
to that motion representative Leon um no
this amendment uh I think we discussed
it with the amendment language thank you
thank you any other discussion
seeing none I'll uh if the clerk is
ready yep I'll ask him to call the roll
motion is ought to pass is amended on
House Bill 136.
representative lamb yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes representative
McLean yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Reed yes representative
pelosov yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay
representative friedas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro yes
representative priest yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Howard
and representative McDonald yes
twenty to zero
there's no objection we will put that on
the consent calendar
next up is House Bill 575
representative profile do you have a
motion
yes I move ought to pass on House Bill
575. is there a second
representative Leon seconds
representative profile do you want to
speak to your motion sure I think House
Bill 575
um
I think raises a very important issue
which is that
we we have seen cases of uh of vaccines
that are not that have not been through
clinical trials
that the state of New Hampshire is is uh
is promoting and I think that uh you
know it it deserves further conversation
and and that we ought to uh
we ought to not be promoting those sorts
of uh those sorts of untested or
minimally tested vaccines in the state
of New Hampshire
thank you other discussion
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman one of my concerns I have
around this is that taxpayers shouldn't
be paying for advertising that should be
done by the pharmaceutical companies so
that's one of the reasons why I think
that this is important
another discussion yes representative
Murphy thank you on
I will um
vote against this for several reasons
one some of the wording here I think is
a bit odd and inappropriate voluntary
human clinical trials really is an
unnecessary word you don't need
voluntary in fact involuntary trials
would be actually unethical and illegal
to do so
um if you were to have this go forward
mandating
you know a clinical trial for every
vaccine and every change in vaccine
there will be certain significant
negative side effects one of which would
be
the fact that simply the the flu vaccine
is would be in jeopardy with this bill
the flu vaccine is updated every year
based on the prior you know
symptomatology in the strain that goes
through the population it doesn't have
to go and doesn't go through a human
trial so that would be a potential
vaccine that would be compromised in its
use
um the um the folks from New Hampshire
hospital and even the correctional
facilities have also stated that
um If This Were to go through it'd
really make it difficult for them to get
vaccines to places like the correctional
facilities in New Hampshire hospital and
those people that are in very high risk
because of the um
um the congregate living that they are
living in
um
there is
um the also the potential uh unintended
consequence is the the compassionate use
of vaccines you know uh or any drug it
doesn't have to be a vaccine it could be
a drug an implant or any other device
without the compassionate use of a
vaccine that would be delayed by having
the net by necessary by necessity to go
through a human clinical trial would
really compromise the ability of
compassionate use and that has been done
in the past with things like muscular
dystrophy ALS certain cancers so
um I I every vaccine every medicine
every product that is put into a patient
whether it's um you know for Orthopedic
care or whether it's a drug whether it's
a vaccine
I understand they all should be vetted
try it you know in in cleared in a way
that's um protective of the patient but
the the fact that this would mandate
that they have to go through this um
uh this um this this trial would really
compromise the ability to update
um pneumococcal vaccines
um and um for those reasons I mentioned
above I would probably vote against it
thank you thank you
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman um I just want to
speak to the uh idea that there it's
unethical and uh that involuntary
clinical trials cannot take place that
used to be the way that it was but in
2016 the common rule was amended and now
um an IRB can determine that they can
have uh informed consent of being in a
clinical trial waived for a participant
um so we we can have involuntary
um you know in involvement in a clinical
trial unfortunately
um so I do think that the patients
um consent is you know
uh foundational in any scientific
research and that being said we we need
those clinical trials if the state is
going to get involved in promoting or or
purchasing or Distributing something it
needs to have that strong Research
Foundation and nothing will preclude the
companies themselves from
um besides existing law from uh you know
advertising and reaching out to those
vulnerable people who might need the
newer
advancements in medication and biologics
representative McLean
thank you Mr chair
um was there an amendment coming on this
to oh so I think you know absent and I I
think we learned a lot of the wrong
lessons out of covid but I do think
though that this bill by prohibiting the
state from purchasing promoting and
distributing I think it's it's just
incredibly Broad and I I think you know
it
really limits potential course of action
going forward I mean I
I'm kind of sympathetic on the promoted
side but the other stuff I just I just I
just don't feel given the breadth of
this bill that I can support it at this
time
representative Palmer
so the other thing is I know in in
particular in pediatric practices a lot
of the vaccines are provided by the
state and without that
um a lot of families can't afford the
vaccines that they choose to have and
and those include the ones that are
required for schools so
um I would want to make absolutely sure
that that that doesn't get interfered
with because it could end up being a
large cost to patients who can't afford
it
thank you
yeah representative Shapiro
thank you I would just like to give an
example of um I have a family member
who's passed away but lived in the
Glencliff home for probably 10 or 12
years prior to passing away and for for
those of you who don't know what the
Glen Cliff home is it's run by the it's
the only I think the only psychiatric
Nursing Home in the country that's run
by a state so it's it's it's it's
part of the state hospital the New
Hampshire hospital system so in order to
live there you have to
um
have severe psychiatric problems
um severe and persistent mental illness
and you also have to be medically
vulnerable so my brother-in-law lived
there for quite a long time they took
fantastic care of him
um
not that he would have ever agreed to
take a vaccine
but the idea that um
that they wouldn't have been able to
talk to him about taking a flu vaccine
and encouraged him to take a flu vaccine
and give it to him if he was willing I
think we're really
um
compromising the care for some very
vulnerable people with this bill
um
so I I will vote against it thank you
representative Weber
and then you were getting very close to
what I was going to say when you
referenced the Glen Cliff home but I'm
thinking about our County nursing homes
as well which
again another vulnerable and congregate
population that benefits very much from
having the vaccines and the state
involvement with the procurement
of the discussion representative
palazzov
uh I I will be voting uh for this bill I
think it's a good prudent idea to have a
proper clinical trial before the
government being involved so heavily in
medication and we are in state of Crisis
we are
mandating to certain populations this
so-called vaccines that
is not necessarily because it doesn't
stop a transmission of
sales cov2 and we have like in New
Hampshire we have one kid who died of
covet and four kids who died from side
effects after receiving this vaccine and
there are many indications that blood
diseases are up and
certain nervous systems are up after
introdu reduction of this and we never
tested it
for kids we never tested actually if
they benefit
there was no double blind status for for
minus and and we know that covid-19 is
not as severe on younger population and
it's not the first time when
vaccine in the history of humanity in in
the last 100 years that some vaccines or
medications had some unexpected side
effects so uh
uh right now we assuming that
flu vaccines and other vaccines don't
need to be tested because they're always
good but what if some modification to
those Technologies
won't be beneficial and we say oh no
don't test it so I think this bill is a
good idea
thank you
of the discussion a representative Weber
and while I think that representative
Palazzo makes some very good points with
respect to
uh the uncertainties of the covid
vaccine this is too broad because it
would also prohibit us from Distributing
the flu vaccine every year and that's
something that people in the County
nursing homes in Congress living in the
prisons need but it doesn't get tested
each year it's reformulated but it
doesn't get tested on humans it just
goes straight into arms and so I think
that as drafted this bill is over abroad
and although I understand the
protections that people might want from
newer
product
this I'm afraid will put real burdens
both on uh
things like the influenza vaccine both
for children and for for elders
of the discussion representative Leon um
thank you Mr chairman
um the question about these other
vaccines is one that's quite interesting
especially when you look at the full
approval process for things like the
influenza vaccine there are predicate
approvals and predicate drugs that
they're based off of so the initial flu
vaccine did have these clinical trials
and FDA approval mechanisms allow for
follow-on studies and they allow for
certain developments and new
introductions that are building off of
those studies with with voluntary human
clinical trials that are conducted in a
high quality way this actually is an
area on the vaccine part I went to a
vaccine conference on development of new
vaccines back at MIT
just after our first SARS experience and
all of those technologies that they were
looking at then built off predicate
vaccines a lot of this challenge here
with our most recent experience with the
MRNA vaccines is that they're not
building off of a predicate that has
gone through this level of clinical
trial this is not the same as when you
have a follow-on approval it's entirely
different and my reading of the bill
does not stop any of these products that
have a predicate approval it's not a
formulation change because it is still
based off of an approval based on
voluntary human trials I I appreciate
that we all read the bills differently
but I read this as those predicate
trials are adequate to it and that we
need to know that this at least began
with something that had the appropriate
balance of safety and efficacy in order
to pass through the FDA approval process
yes representative Reed thank you Mr
chairman my concern too with the vaccine
such as the coveted vaccine is that the
MRNA technology will be used to
formulate our more standard vaccines
such as the flu vaccine and other
childhood vaccines will be switched to
an mRNA technology and I do think that
this might protect against that so
um I I am in support of this I do I will
be thank you thank you now that is
representative Weber
I'm just going to say
I can understand that position much as I
don't agree with it but that's not what
the bill says as it's drafted so
um you know it may be a drafting error
but the bill is drafted doesn't have
those reservations in it that I can see
other discussion
I'm seeing no other discussion
okay with that I'll ask the clerk to
call the roll a motion is
ought to pass on House Bill 575.
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes
representative McLean no
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Reed yes
representative
peloso yes
representative Weber no
representative McKay
representative Freitas no
representative Cannon nope
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro no representative
priests no
representative Murphy uh no
representative Palmer no
representative Howard
and representative McDonald yes
on 9 4 11 against
and move itl motion's been made for itl
is there a second
representative farmer
okay any discussion representative Weber
do you want to speak to that motion or
have we just talked enough no thanks I'm
I'm going to hope that one of our
Medical
qualified people might write the blurb
but we'll discuss that afterwards
for the discussion on this
see none if the clerk is ready I'll ask
him to call the roll representative Leon
no
representative Cushman no
or preserve Bill King no
representative Koval no
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King no
representative Missouri no
representative Reed no
Representative peloso no
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon
yes
representative Nutter Upham yeah
representative Shapiro yes
representative priests yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes
representative Howard
and representative McDonald no
11 4 and 9 against
so that that is itl all right and
representative Weber will be working on
nobody's meeting my eye over there
studying their shoes make sure they're
tied properly and
okay we will collaborate and thank you
okay moving on it'll be a minority
foreign
okay next up is
um
oh it's Bill 619 and representative
McLean did you you have an amendment for
that
thank you Mr chair
um I did have an amendment
but it's it's it's not my intention to
uh formally offer at this time
um what I would prefer to do is is make
a motion to retain the bill
and use this amendment kind of as a an
informal springboard by which you know
the committee that would look at it
could work off of I I felt that the the
original bill was just too broad there
was just too much in it so what the
amendment does is it it removes
um the part of the bill that that has to
do with the conversion Theory it takes
that conversion therapy sorry it takes
that out it also takes out the section
with respect to the schools and the
education
we have an education committee that is
looking at a parent's Bill of Rights and
I think that they're better equipped to
to have that kind of conversation
the other thing
um the the findings in the amendment are
really paired down there was a lot of
discussion and a lot of controversy
about the findings itself so I really
just you know in the spirit of kind of
working collaborative collaboratively
just kind of paired all that down
and so really what is left
um what I would hope as a kind of floor
um for study during retention would just
be uh the gender affirming care part of
it and the reason for that I think is
that when I I heard the testimony
um presented in the committee we heard
from glad we heard from the ACLU
and very importantly we heard from
Dartmouth Hitchcock and what I heard
stated over and over again was that the
gender affirming care really is the only
uh
evidence-based approach
um towards looking at dysphoria and you
know that was their word not mine
underscore that word only and I found
that word a little bit problematic
especially in light of some of the later
testimony which said that in Europe
certainly not within all of Europe but
we have we heard about Finland Sweden
Italy France England kind of pivoting
away from the Dutch protocol and looking
more at
um
Psychotherapy up until the age 18 and
going towards that so um so the question
is what was driving that and I don't
really think that in the hearings we
were able to get sufficient answer to
that question you know was that being
driven by politics was that being driven
by actual you know evidentiary findings
I I don't think we know but I think
um it may be worthwhile for this
committee to look at that especially in
light of the fact of the the the
opponents of the bill
continual reassertion of saying the the
gender affirming care is the only
approach and sometimes I think when when
you put that forward that can be a
little bit closed-minded and I think
there's a lot to benefit by going
through and understanding why did
certainly not all of Europe but some
very important countries within Europe
decide to move away from what had been a
standard treatment towards Psychotherapy
so uh long and short of it I'd like to
retain the bill and use this as a kind
of a guideline for what the floor should
be and that's where I'm at thank you
you're moving to retain
is there a second to that motion
representative Cannon put her hand up
representative
okay yes
you're moving this second thing okay
another discussion
seeing uh yes representative Missouri
yeah I concur with representative McLean
after all of those hearings I proceeded
to really dig into and do a lot of
research on what's coming out of Sweden
France UK Etc and have found some really
interesting information in that of which
I didn't know before so I would like
more time to dig into
um and also some stories of
um adults who have gone through that
experience and and what physically
they're experiencing today some of which
we did here during the hearing so I I
would appreciate more time to to just
dig into a lot of this more
thank you
another discussion
representative palazzov
so so one testimonia
against this bill included situation
when a minor was coached by
all the man who was I believe 42 and I
was actually like Predator receiving
some sexual favors from that minor but
also being the only person
who was encouraging that minor in a
journey of
being a person of a new gender and I see
it situation as could be seen both ways
as for this bill or but also
against this bill
or vice versa so when we move with minus
and irreversible changes I think we need
to be a caution and I understand the
argument that
Suicidal Thoughts can also lead to
irreversible circumstances but I I
I deny the premise that
uh
sex change for a significant portion of
our minus is a protrudent way to go and
I I would support the bill as it is but
I respect about the representative
McLean presented to us that we need more
data to understand uh if there are other
approaches scientifically based so thank
you thank you representative Murphy
thank you Mr chairman and
um it's amazing to me that after
listening to Neely
a hundred um testimonies 93 sorry
um it's amazing to me that I would come
away with any questions left I would
have thought everything would have been
answered but I actually think I came
away with more questions than I had
answers to
um and as a result of that I called a
physician an endocrinologist at
Dartmouth who has been running the
transgender program for the last four
decades and I spent an hour with them on
the phone on on Friday trying to
understand questions I had about
um the the the difficulties of The
Adolescents through puberty and the
difficulties with the um uh in how many
how many patients that go through
transition actually have regret buyers
regret and he told me it was actually
very small maybe two to four percent
also trying to get an understanding and
I asked actually the question
in the public hearing of the physician
who was a resident at Dartmouth
um about the reversibility or not of
some of the um the drugs and she did not
know but um uh Dr Turco actually
mentioned me that you know you can go
through the um uh puberty halting drugs
and that can be very much reversible uh
even with the hormones that they use
later uh in their teenage years but no
transition surgery is done until well
into their adulthood So after talking to
him and after
understanding with uh with Dr uh with um
what representative McLean wants to put
forward
um my sense would be that to retain this
to better understand for all of us to
better understand because honestly I
think all of us have a lot of questions
and if we have more of these questions
answered we can come up with a much
better bill in some shape or form so I
appreciate the effort to put forward a a
concept um going forward and I would
vote for retention as well thank you
thank you when we say that uh no
significant side effects those puberty
blockers
being prescribed off level so again to
the discussion that there was no
appropriate testing for them thank you
other representative Cushman thank you
Mr chairman
um so I am going to support the retained
motion
um I do think that the bill needs more
work I do think there are a lot of
concerns that are valid
um in society on both sides of this uh
generally I Am pro parents rights and I
think that there's probably some Middle
Ground here whether it's a waiting
period that needs to be had before
anyone goes forward with certain
therapies or procedures or
um you know some other less heavy-handed
way of helping families navigate this
and make sure that
um the pros and cons are you know
weighed
uh adequately
and that none of these you know just to
try to protect sometimes there's a
social phenomenon that can push people
to make decisions hastily
um I do I will support it um so that we
can work on it a little bit more
and uh that's all thank you
representative Shapiro
yes thank you Mr chairman um
clearly in the minority but I would much
I'm totally ready to vote itl on this um
but won't have the opportunity to I mean
I I view this
um
you know if this was my child and they
were go or anybody I knew and they were
going to be
um using hormone treatments or surgery
before 18 or after 18.
um I would be very very concerned and
worried maybe freaked out
um
but as a parent
if my child is under 18 I see it as my
job to engage with them and come up with
a decision as a family if it's after 18
you know I can have my say but it's
really my job to accept my young adults
decision and still
love them
and so I see I view this very much as um
parents I wouldn't I probably wouldn't
use the word term parents rights but
family rights
and so I
would be totally okay with
sending this bill away but
you know in the spirit of consensus and
in the spirit of it's always good to
learn more about something before we do
that
um I will vote to retain it thank you
representative profile
yeah I I also uh I will support a
routine motion I I think there
I think the the
there's a lot in this bill that requires
work I share the concerns that
representative McLean has has raised
um I I think there's just we're we're
early enough in this that I think that
there the the long-term impact of some
of these procedures on children is
really
uh not well known
um and I think that that we need to
understand if there are changes
happening elsewhere in the world why is
that and what is in the best interest of
those children I also I just think there
are some things in this bill that that
need work and I'll give you one example
is at the very end of the bill
um you know it says no insurer that
issues or renews a policy for health
insurance
um
et cetera Etc shall be required uh oh it
shall be required okay I I was uh I was
reading it as a as a uh a mandate
similar to the above so that's my my bad
for uh for misreading that one
nevertheless there there are other
examples throughout the bill that I
think are just
um poorly conceived and really require
some work so I will be voting for the
motion to retain okay thank you
representative Cannon and then
representative Murphy
thank you
um
I would love to kill it as well however
I did get
um
I did get a lot of questions in my mind
as well based on some of the comments
yes and um
so I'd like to do some delving into that
myself
uh
I have had numerous I've worked with
numerous parents and their kids over the
past 20 years
and and I know that they want to do the
right thing for their children as well
and for us to just put something in
place without doing further
investigation would be
wrong
so we need to do some additional work on
it I actually think what representative
McLean has done is as far as an
amendment goes closer to what I was even
thinking about so I'm willing to work
with that and work with some people here
to do the right thing
thank you representative Murphy thank
you once again I I too would um Echo
representative Shapiro's sentiment I too
would be inclined on its surface at the
face surface to itls Bill no question in
my mind however
I I hearken back to when representative
Roy first
stated that after you know last week
when he started out his comment was
important that he said I want to get the
discussion going because it's not out
there so if you come away from hearing
93 testimonies and you still have
questions and it forces you to call
providers elsewhere it strikes me that
we all are lacking in a lot of the
information that we could benefit from
so if for for no other reason to retain
the bill and bring it back it's not to
kick it down the road it's basically to
bring it back so that we can inform
ourselves because if we killed it today
or pass it today in one way your shape
or form it's going to come back again in
some other form it will come back so I
think that by retaining it pairing it
down as representative McLean did we can
then move forward to educate ourselves
and make a better build going forward
board so yes I would rather on its
surface itl but I am more than happy to
retain so that we can be informed better
going forward
thank you
of the discussion
seeing no other discussion that'll ask
the clerk to call a roll motion is to
retain house bill 619.
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes representative
McLean yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Reed yes
representative pelosa yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon
yes
representative Nutter Upham yeah
representative Shapiro yes
representative priests
yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Howard yes
and representative McDonald yes
20 to zero
okay my house bill 619 is retained
to go grab another form
okay yeah if we could have a brief
recess we need another green form to
record a
oh we change bills don't go on the
calendar
please
our clerk always comes prepared you must
have been a Boy Scout
we've all been here
but I could use the bathroom break oh
yes all right yeah a request has been
made for a bathroom break so yeah let's
how about a 10 minute recess
just in case the bathrooms are busy
together
three hours
well no I'm not
right
upstairs
and and I don't have anything else
no
but I'd like
five minutes
okay
and I have to certainly have a good time
to do that research and appreciate
the benefits
it is and and you know we've parked in
strong as a different reasons sometimes
sometimes we really do need to get a
whole bunch of people together yeah and
we have a couple of those
can happen and then some of um
yeah
put this one on fields yes
foreign
[Music]
looks like select meeting
before here
so funny
jokes
thank you again
sometimes
um
and I kept hearing everything everywhere
and all at once and my side feels very
much oh
of course
um
foreign
yeah
I have to tell you this is
hype
um
about it
well I
struggling yeah
it wasn't even my original
is that there's a lot of medical
professionals
um
between
[Music]
um
our information
yeah
tonight
what they want
but it's hard because
um
all right we should probably get going
remember this could be start taking
their seats
it was a long 10 minutes but worthwhile
okay we only have a couple bills left
um next one I would like to go to is a
house bill 368 and I'll recognize
representative Cannon
I moved to retain I'll spell 368. okay
is there a second
representative Leon seconds
representative Cannon do you want to
speak to your motion yes
um
it was a struggle
for me to do this but it's a I think it
would be a good thing for us to to
discuss this a little more um I I find
this this a benefit for our medical
community to be able to have some
protections from outside sources for
sharing information about their patients
especially when it comes down to legal
matters outside the state so I think
that
this this bill is limited in Focus
primarily to um
our transgender Community but there may
be more
more people in a broader sense as far as
other issues that need the same
protections and instead of just doing
one
small piece of the pie is to look at it
on a little broader level and and I
think we could make it better and not
just focusing on one Community but on a
lot of the medical medical community and
the information that people have been
asking for outside the state especially
when it comes to legal issues
thank you
other discussion
of Representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for sharing that
um I do think that there's a lot of
misunderstandings around HIPAA and
exactly what privacy protections there
are we assume that there's some
protections that are in place there's
other ones where we don't understand
those implications and I do think that
this brings up this is a clear
indication of where where bat we're
pitting States against States and that
there's a particular desire to have this
protection but better understanding
patient privacy and protecting people
here in New Hampshire I think should be
a broader conversation and I think we
might be able to do something really
phenomenal not just for our transgender
friends but for everybody
other discussion
seeing none I will ask Clark to call the
role a motion is to retain post bill
368.
representative Leon
yes representative Cushman
yes representative Bill King yes
representative kofalt yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Reed yes
representative yes
representative Weber yes
representative representative McKay
I was not president I'm sorry
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative priest yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes
representative Howard
and representative McDonald yes 19-0
okay and the final bill for our
consideration today is House Bill 608
and I know we're waiting for an
amendment
um
yes representative Shapiro Mr chairman
can I just make a general comment that's
not related to
that's you know a specific Bill oh sure
I I just think um
you know this um
representative Leon's comments about
HIPAA kind of make me think that we deal
with a lot of very kind of technical
policies that are really difficult for
people to understand who study it all
the time and we're not those people so I
I'm just it makes me think I've often
thought this about Medicaid and now I'm
thinking about HIPAA if um you know in
the future as time goes on if we could
have some continuing education in our
committee on like those kind of specific
topics because we have to we have to
make decisions based on knowledge about
those things and to a large extent we
get experts to tell us but I think we
could use some more general information
to generally understand those and I'm
sure there are other topics as well it's
a good point and I I could follow up
with the Department if you want on that
when I was at the department we took a a
crash course on it like a webinar or
something and it's an incredibly
complicated uh massive thing but but any
insight we could gain would be that much
you know that much further ahead for us
good good point but yeah in fact
representative Williams
um maybe you could uh
advise me on that we can talk later but
uh about uh doing something like that so
thank you
representative Weber the joy of that is
that you could also perhaps make it
available to other members of the house
and and now that we have the recording
capability uh people who can't attend
have the opportunity to watch it online
which is an incredible benefit not only
to us but to our constituents as well
so I think it's a great idea
okay great
okay any other comments uh while we're
waiting for the amendment on House Bill
608.
yes representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman um on my way off to lunch I
made the fortune or mistake of walking
past the finance committee um division
three and they were looking at some of
the sections of the budget that did not
actually have any fiscal impacts um
division one had sent some of those on
for consideration to the policy
committee and
um I don't know how it happens but
they're interested in our insights on um
the the part the sections 282 283 and
284 on receiving facilities so basically
those around the essentially the Mental
Health crisis receiving facilities and
how to deal with those so we'll find out
more how we're going to do that but if
we can take a look at that part of the
budget and see what Insight we can
provide while they're playing with the
numbers we try and figure out what we
need to do to protect our people
you know representative Weber
I was going to suggest that while we're
waiting for an official Amendment
perhaps representative Leon can tell us
what the amendment contains
because I am currently
without
direction as I mean I I would very much
like knowing what I know now to retain
House Bill 608
um
but oh well we may have it right in
front of us
um I'm I'm willing to entertain any any
kind of other suggestions and I think
we've gone a long way by
listening to each other and and
throwing out different ideas but
um as long as they're here I'll stop
talking and let you pass them out
if you want to open the executive
session on 608
anyway as the amendment goes around let
us officially open the
open I Can Begin our consideration of
House Bill 608 representative Leon thank
you um I guess to make this official
with this I would move amendment
2023-0954h to House Bill 608
which has been made is there a second
this is just for discussion purposes
we're not voting it representative
Cushman seconds representative Leon
would you like to speak to your motion
um yes thank you very much this is um an
amendment that um was crafted with help
of the department
um this
I put a lot of work working with the
Department in order to figure out what a
successful pilot program would look like
it has a six-month pilot program it has
a minimum of 10 agencies providing
Direct Services for geographic
representation and as it moves through
this is one where it's providing status
reports to Health and Human Services
oversight committee and Reporting in
with them to make sure that everybody's
voices are heard within the process and
it requires the department to seek any
waivers to implement this pilot from CMS
and if they're not able to get those
waivers that they'll need to go to
Health and Human Services for
um for approval
so there is also a phased implement it
speaks to a phased implementation plan
to print permits system modifications is
needed to best support the individuals
and families through the transition to
nearest Services rates Technologies and
so this um
it also delays the full implementation
without a pilot to no sooner than
January 1st 2024 to allow it to be
aligned with the individual support plan
dates and not get in the way of the
person-centered planning
um one part that I wanted to add to this
as well would have been a requirement
for the Department to seek waivers to
the continued access the the cap to make
sure that we seek the waivers for direct
billing and we seek the waivers around
conflict-free case management especially
making use of the only willing and only
willing and available I forget the
specific language
and to check in with over Health and
Human Services oversight to make sure
that not only are
people speaking from the community but
that oversight is able to recognize that
there is that that either their their
concerns are being heard even if they're
not acted on and to serve as
representatives for the communities that
are impacted
um that part I I tried to figure out how
to get that language to charge the
department to do that and to hopefully
encourage them to do that through this
process I do know that with the bill
that we we passed before on emerging
medical Technologies last year when we
had Catherine Rogers bill instead of
passing it we moved it to oversight
where it became the responsibility of
oversight and I'm not sure the exact
mechanism to do so but I would hope that
we can ask oversight to pursue with the
Department these waivers to provide all
of that encouragement and emphasis that
might be needed to CMS in order to
increase the odds of success of those
waivers and to also not look to
implement it on the last day of a
two-year waiver but to try and get it as
going as soon as possible so that
there's still time on the clock to deal
with any challenges as they come about
that shouldn't be a two-year delay it
should just be a little breathing room
to get this done the right way in the
New Hampshire way
um and and so with this this would keep
this moving forward in order to have a
pilot plan
based off the recommendations from the a
m report this this does have support
this has been passed around this this
language had come to us it had come
around before and it had also gone to
some of the stakeholders and while there
were different points of concern it it
had General acceptance on this this
isn't a perfect solution but this is
going to help us find a better
implementation and so I really ask that
you support this so that we can move
this forward and move this process so
that it continue its path over in the
Senate even if it does adapt on that
side and we figure out how best to help
the Bureau of Developmental services do
this redesign in a way where people are
respected heard and acknowledged in a
way that they hear
other representative Palmer
so I I just have a question looking at
uh sex section eight
um and it the my question is around this
that I understood there are sort of two
parts to this one is the absolute
required parts of the direct billing and
cut
um conflict of interesting which was
supposed to start we're supposed to
start on July 1st and then the other
pieces of the pie which came through the
a m report and this sort of seems to say
that you know if CMS doesn't authorize
the pilot but that are you I'm just I
guess I'm a little confused uh if I can
answer that sure the whole process is
very confusing the pilot program itself
and some of the implementations where it
would require different waivers from CMS
waivers seem to be one of the ways that
they operate that these are the rules
and then this is how we accommodate all
the different states and
um you know that might be a bit of a
mischaracterization but as I was
reviewing a lot of information from
different states and different
presentations CMS provided to the states
it basically laid out that here's our
path and here's our waivers that
accommodate you and so that would be a
practice because if we require them to
have waivers but then CMS didn't improve
them if we didn't have this language in
here to give them another option they'd
either be in conflict with with Federal
Regulations or state law if they were
unable to do it without without an
approved waiver so may I follow up so
if
if basically CMS doesn't give a waiver
and the and the um agency has to start
the the finance piece and the conflict
of interest peace on July 1st
the pilot program still can go forward
later
the pilot program that's been within
this actually doesn't touch on those
parts on the direct billing uh the
direct billing compliance or the
conflict of it conflict-free case
management representative Weber then
representative McLean
okay so this is really a lot to digest
at the last minute and
I am very concerned that we are
digesting it at the last minute with no
stakeholders in the room and I don't
know what kind of I mean this is
something that should have gone through
a robust subcommittee process and didn't
and I understand that we had time frames
and and all of that but I'm I'm
concerned about that uh because in
trying to solve the problem I'm not at
all convinced that we're going to solve
anything rather than create more
problems for people
um so
I have several questions if I may uh the
first is that this seems to be codifying
into statute the a m report and the
recommendations of the a m report and
what I heard from a lot of people
sitting out there at the hearing
that we had was that they very much
disagreed with the a m report and were
very concerned about its implementation
so one of the things I would be very
concerned about doing without more input
is
codifying that report into statute so
that's item number one
and then the second thing that I I think
I heard you say that this would request
would require people to seek waivers for
the conflict stuff which is the stuff
that we're really bumping up against in
terms of deadlines and I don't see
anything in here that requires that
it just says shall seek waivers to
implement the pilot and I don't think
that's the same waiver because the
conflict is not the pilot program the
conflict is what people need to get done
before then
um so
I may have heard you wrong because I was
trying to read and listen at the same
time but
um if if
this is a requirement of seeking a
waiver on the conflict which I think
would be a good thing to do because I'm
hearing from a lot of people that
they're really worried about that
um I don't think this language does that
so those are my two concerns and uh
initial concerns but I've got more than
that in that
the community isn't here for us the
stakeholders aren't here for us to hear
from them
and I would like to hear from the
Department if the Department's willing
to give us an opinion
representative Leon thank you as to the
part about seeking waivers for the July
1st you're correct that those are not in
here my question was how we can direct a
process through oversight like we did
with the Katherine Rogers biomarkers
bill last year when that was sent to
oversight to deal with it as a
subcommittee as opposed to doing this is
that something that this committee would
need to take action on or would
oversight be able to do so on its own
representative Weber well that one
oversight can do it on their own uh I
think somebody from this committee ought
to go and ask them to do it and and
their
if it's going to be a request of the
committee then the committee as a whole
has to come to some kind of consensus
but the fact is that they can they are
Allowed by Statute to appoint any
subcommittees they want to appoint and
so it could be as simple as a matter of
several of us going and saying look
these are the things we want to deal
with
I would be much more comfortable
retaining this bill and referring
issues to the oversight committee now
the problem with that is that
if we pass this it has the force of Law
and people have to do it the oversight
committee makes recommendations and
sometimes one of the recommendations is
we ought to pass a law
but they cannot mandate
the department do anything they can
suggest they can congole they can
poke but but they can't
actually mandate anything so I mean if
if there's something we want to mandate
it has to be in statute but I'm really
concerned about this language going into
statute
if it's a matter of a less formal
appearance before the oversight
committee then I'm I'm happier about
that
um
and you know I think
the one concern that I I have I mean I
think I think we really do share most of
the same concerns uh the concern I share
with you is uh we do need to make sure
that things are progressing along and uh
I don't know whether that's
I mean that that would be best done in a
statute if we were all agreed as to how
to draft the statute and what goes in
there uh but it
I think the second best thing because we
don't have that would be to retain the
bill
the department can still proceed and we
I think it's pretty clear from what
we've heard that they're not
going to proceed with the a m part of
the implementation until after they've
solved the Brazilian questions that
they've got about the conflict of
interest stuff
uh so I feel less anxious about kicking
the can down the road
um but I would feel a lot more
comfortable I think if what we did was
retain the bill work on this language
and then have have oversight
ask for
you know what one of the things they can
certainly do regularly is ask for
updates on this every single month when
they meet
and perhaps have a subcommittee to delve
into it further
but I think that this is something that
the legislative action ought to be taken
with more input from stakeholders and
and and really carefully drafted
because the last thing we want to do is
put more roadblocks in the way of a
population that's already and I know
that that's not the intent but but it's
my concern that we might get there
representative
well I'm not going to sound as learned
and astute as my colleague
representative Weber but my memory of
when the stakeholders were here that
given a choice between retaining this
bill or retaining them being able to
move their budgets around to pay for
things
their choice was that the being able to
manipulate their budgets efficiently was
the one they wanted us to pass and this
was the one that they were okay with us
retaining so others of you that remember
that
but I think that's good input and could
I make a call clarification none of that
was learned that was me saying this is
all the stuff I don't know
just in case you missed that McLean and
then representative Shapiro
yeah I mean I
I do have similar concerns I think just
looking at this the way it's going
forward it looks like the AL the a m
thing is going to be come because you're
expanding the pilot from just two area
agencies basically to all 10 area
agencies it looks like this is going to
be more of an implementation than and
then an evaluation because the original
one had been just hey we're going to try
this out on two area agencies as an
evaluation this expands it out to all
ten so it does kind of have the feeling
of this is more of an implementation
um and where there was a lot of is the
two-tier approach really the way to go
we heard a lot of pushback on that and
then I share representative Weber's
concerned we heard the testimony here
that they really want to have the the
stick on the the July 1st and so what I
kind of walked away from is we're going
to go on July 1st and
if it doesn't work well we're gonna do
our best to make people whole because
that's what we do and is CMS okay with
that ah so I don't know what there is in
here to really push them to pursue the
waiver and I'm not as familiar with the
oversight process having never touched
it in my entire life so um but it's
totally gone from here so I think those
are my concerns at this point
representative Shapiro
yes I hope not to just repeat
representative McLean but you know when
I think of a pilot program I think of
small time limited short time limited
and when I read this it seems to have so
many aspects and all 10 area agencies so
um maybe I'm just reading maybe I'm just
reading it wrong but um I'm having
trouble Discerning why this
you know the difference between
implementation and a you know a pilot
program to actually learn something
representative Leon thank you well just
as one point it's not 10 area agencies
it's 10 agencies that provide Direct
Services so those that contract with
them okay thank you I didn't understand
of the discussion
okay so actually representative Leon um
thank you I think um my biggest concern
is making sure that this process has
oversight so I don't know if the correct
way to do that would be to withdraw this
amendment
um have a formal motion or formal
statement from this committee about
Health and Human Services oversight
taking this on so that they can make
sure that the stakeholders are heard and
then retaining this bill I don't know
how we would proceed with that
specifically and I'd seek advice on how
to make that happen but I think that
would satisfy what we're trying to do
especially if that statement says you
know with the understanding that the a m
that that there won't be adoption of the
a m until we've addressed until we've
addressed the issues with the federal
compliance on Direct payment and
conflict-free case resolution that would
not be advancing further on the a m and
to work with open and for oversight to
work with that
the only
as I understand it and I'm going to wait
for a researcher because she may have
been offering useful advice but if we
want to mandate that something happens
after something else then we have to
pass a statute that says that that's the
only way we can do that
uh but we can certainly and and what I
heard was people aren't ready to
implement that yet in any case
uh and what I further heard was that
with the staff they have now they're
going to be working double time for some
time after July 1st just to deal with
the compliance issues
what we can do is we can ask our chair
who serves on the Health and Human
Services oversight committee supported
by the other members of this committee
who are either serving members or
alternates on the committee to put this
forward at our next meeting
um March 24th all right and
um
we have always had enormous cooperation
from the chair
of that committee
in this thing and I know I'm pretty sure
because I I've talked to him or I
mentioned it to him and I think he
already has
ongoing reports about this issue as
something that he wants to hear from
just to explain a little bit about the
Health and Human Services oversight
committee it's a it's a joint committee
it's senators and representatives
generally it doesn't do much what it
does is here
all of these reports that we mandate
that come around once a year once a
quarter sometimes once a month when
we're when we were implementing the
doorways project we got a report every
month on the implementation so at a
minimum somebody from Health and Human
Services who knows who is intimately
involved with that
um
has to come and explain what's happened
over the course of the month so
you hear the updates and you get to ask
the questions about all the things that
your constituents have asked you about
and other legislators have asked you
about
the other thing to her great credit is
our current
I believe it's acting commissioner comes
every month and is there at the
beginning of the meeting so she's there
to be asked anything
but I think that there's certainly a
great deal of bipartisan concern about
this issue and I think it's something
that we can get
the Health and Human Services oversight
to take up either as a committee or as a
subcommittee for a subcommittee you have
to present a plan of what the
subcommittee is and what the
subcommittee is going to do so that's a
little more formal
uh but again it's just filing a written
submission so that they can
take into account what the subcommittee
is going to do and I think for this
where there may be extra work that that
really might be the way to go and the
only limit on subcommittees for the
Health and Human Services oversight
committee is the subcommittee has to be
chaired by one of the members of the
oversight committee but they can pull in
either other legislative members or
other non-legislative members if that's
going to be helpful and we've done that
for various special projects in the past
so it's a very flexible
thing but it it doesn't have the power
to mandate because it's not
it's a legislative oversight body it's
not the body that does the legislation
and I guess my my concern would be given
the given the time frame that we're
operating under if we retain this bill
and find that we need something to be
done we can certainly do it in January
and if it's exigent enough we could and
we have the
consent of the Senate and the governor
we could do it very quickly
um from what I understand from our
researcher this was I spill a similar
bill was ideal of last time and sent to
oversight do you know what happened with
it at Alpha site
I was not a member of oversight last
term yesterday
representative uh
yes um
I'm not understanding maybe it hasn't
been determined yet but I'm not
understanding what we're asking the
Health and Human Services oversight
committee to deal with are we just
asking them to keep track of the changes
that have to happen by July 1 or are we
asking them to actually Implement a
um a pilot program or can DHHS Implement
a pilot program on their own and then
the then the oversight committee would
keep track of it I'm not really clear
what we're asking them to do if
representative Weber
I'm looking at represent representative
Williams at attorney Williams in the
back who's occasionally nodding and
occasionally shaking his head and
smiling
um
and he may be able to help me with what
was referred to the committee last time
because he does come to the committee
meetings or sets them up and it may be
it's it's okay I don't think we need to
do a great deal on that uh they can't
set up stuff or mandate anything uh they
can advise they can ask for information
they can suggest they can nudge about
what anything that has to do with the
Department of healthy and well there are
two things here what I'm trying to get
at is
one of the things you suggested is will
they implement this program and they
have no authority to implement anything
and I want that to be clear
so my first point is if you want to
implement or mandate something you have
to put it in statute only we're not
clear enough on what we're implementing
or mandating yet for me to be willing to
agree to it
um
what they can do is they can certainly
ask people to come and Report every
month as to what is happening so first
of all you just have eyes on the process
which I think is incredibly useful the
other thing is that just by virtue of
the fact that a number of different
people from HHS have to come and sit in
the room at the same time and listen to
legislators
they often find non-legislative
solutions to all kinds of stuff that
doesn't need legislative Solutions
with respect to a pilot project and I
think Mr Williams will correct me if I'm
wrong about this I hope he will
um
the department can already do that and
he's going like this so I'm pretty sure
I'm on Solid Ground
our Our concern is we want to make sure
they are doing that and that's one of
the things that Health and Human
Services oversights fairly good at doing
is focusing people's minds month by
month on okay it's another month where
are we now and just knowing just knowing
that you have that deadline is often
those of us who work better under
deadlines I'm I'm I'm motivated by an
approaching deadline to get certain
things done
but
I'm
we don't need to have
a hugely well articulated
mission unless we want a specific
subcommittee
to do a specific thing
and and I think maybe we could discuss
that informally a bit more before
um before the 24th
um
or we could just as a as as Health and
Human Services oversight ask for
progress reports on this particular
issue
and I he who keeps the agenda keeps
nodding his head when I say this you
know I can't speak for representative
Pearson because he's the chair of the
committee but we have several members of
the committee here and and
um
I I don't see a lot of controversy and I
think I think the issue is we want to
make sure that things are being pushed
along and the question that we all have
is how best to do that I did
misunderstand earlier it was other
legislation that was itl them sent over
there it wasn't this particular bill
right so but yeah that is a tremendous
Resource as I understand at the
oversight committee they can pull people
together or work with the Department to
pull people together to to work on this
and address the many of the concerns
representative Weber that you've
expressed about stakeholders being
consulted and so forth
so that representative Leon um thank you
and I did speak with um representative
Pearson who's the chairman of oversight
and um he he also agrees with this need
and that it would be a proper thing for
oversight to be doing and following up
on with his time frame and Mr chairman I
noticed that
um representative Kay also and
representative McKay is himself a former
chair of Health and Human Services
oversight sure go ahead representative
McKay
thank you Mr chairman I was
very taken the other day by
the
anguish that I could see on all sides
that of this issue
I've done this before in terms of going
to the oversight committee as well as
serving on it it's my intention
unfortunately I've got two separate
issues and I think that's probably
unwise to go with two separate issues
but the
a person like me in the legislature can
go to the oversight present a plan
and say this is what I would like to
participate in
I've already talked to representative
Pearson
I've already talked to
representative McMahon
and those are two of the individuals who
have and I think very long history
so that
part of what I was going to do
was dependent on what this committee
would do if somebody passes
legislation then there's no need for me
to
to do that
and the other brand that I have which is
restrained a little bit
is to have a
Committee of
the oversight committee dealing with the
10-year mental health plan
and the specific issues there
in particular
the way in which the
the
so-called borders that thought border
that's an interesting slip the
the borders uh those individuals today
there's probably 30 adults and 25 of 30
children waiting to get into New
Hampshire hospital
one of the things that
can make that move along
is if we use Telehealth one of the
things
that is we're not paying attention to
the law there's a very specific period
of time
that a person goes into a local hospital
the doctor says they need to go to New
Hampshire hospital
but there's a specific period of time
that they have
to have a court from the judge water
the commitment
I am so that
so that my original plan
was to see if we can't get a committee
under the oversight committee to start
to get communication among those
individuals who seem to be not
communicated
the second one is to emphasize
the 10-year plan
I have a particular interest in this I
was chairman of the commission that
wrote the 10-year plan 10 years ago and
we didn't do a damn thing about it you
know that's partly because we were in a
recession and it was difficult
uh but that the
the opportunity is there
and brought away for us that there are
individuals
from this committee who are members
who might very well
volunteer at the chair
just subcommitted and people like me
that are willing to do with work
and so that
I thought it was important to tell the
committee that I intend to go to the
next oversight committee and bring up
these two issues
I don't know where to answer questions
thank you
okay
um
at this point
um representative land do you have any
thoughts
um
so I guess my one question is if we
retain this we can still we can retain
this so we can keep the flexibility and
we can also ask the oversight committee
to work on this correct then if that's
the case I would like to withdraw my
motion about this amendment
and I will also withdraw my set and I
would like to move retain on House Bill
is there a second
representative Weber seconds
any discussion on the motion to retain
House Bill 608
seeing none I'll ask the clock to call
the ball
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Bill King yes
representative kofal yes representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Reed
yes representative pelosa yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative priest yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer
representative Howard yes and
representative McDonald yes 20 to zero
okay and a vote of twenty to zero House
Bill 608 is retained that concludes all
of our bills as I understand it
uh we did it so
and we don't have to come in on
Wednesday now so
enjoy the snow everybody has anybody
else have anything before we adjourn
okay we stand return thank you